peu
[Musique]
alors t'as vu ce qui se passe là tout le
talent non de coutume pas de quoi la
radio ou à la télé les journaux tout le
monde en face à le truc mais oui ce
matin chez lui chers amis chers ennemis
bonsoir la chaîne c'est france 2 et
l'émission s'appelle tout le monde en
parle vous connaissez le principe tout
le monde en parle alors tout le monde en
parle en parle mais avec la nouvelle
année
tout le monde en parle a évolué
l'émission sera et oui plus
divertissantes c'est pour ça que vous
demandez à pêcher gayola laurent ruquier
de nous rejoindre l'émission sera plus
culture alors là évidemment tout de
suite c'est pour ça qu'on a demandé à
laetitia casta d'être là et à pierre
arditi également d'être là alors de quoi
allons nous parler ce soir nous allons
parler du politiquement correct nous
allons nous demander où est passée la
provoc avec christine boutin car 0
thierry pfister guy konopnicki et
laurent alliez on va parler des femmes
on va parler de la femme on va se
demander qui est la femme idéale de l'an
inutile de vous dire que laetitia casta
a de bonnes chances d'être sélectionné
on en parle avec le docteur gros très
sérieux le docteur plus encore plus
sérieux et jean-françois journal et
jean-françois journal photographe
on va parler des anges les anges
existe-t-il alors avec jean charles de
castelbajac est un mordu des anges et
andré bercoff qui n'y croit pas du tout
mais avant de savoir où est passée la
preuve qu'on va faire un petit tour de
table entre nous si vous voulez bien
pour savoir ce dont on parle à part les
sujets dont on vient de parler autour de
vous alors qu'ils aient de quoi on parle
en ce moment parmi les sujets
intéressants il ya un truc dont tout le
monde a parlé c'est évidemment la sphère
du match lens marseille avec le fameux
penalty
oui qui a été refusé par un arbitres à
chaque fois qu'est une faute d'arbitrage
est tout le monde qui se posent des
questions est-ce qu'il faut mettre la
vidéo dans
l'arbitrage est ce qu'il faut aider les
arbitres par la vidéo mais la vidéo elle
y est déjà sur les match après match et
filmé avec tout le monde en parle
effectivement vous avez raison thierry
may 7 ce qui m'agace là dedans ces deux
côtés il faut une fois pour toutes
décidé qu'ils avaient vidé oui ou non
mais à chaque fois qu à une erreur on
reparle de ça c'est évidemment le
problème c'est que si à la vidéo pour
arbitrer les arbitres pourront plus
faire payer pour arbitrer en faveur
d'anne laure déjà les pauvres gens qui
courent beaucoup si en plus il faut
qu'ils courent avec une caméra est déjà
compliquée du football plus laetitia
casta
ça fait trois ballons alors laetitia
vraiment c'est le jour je me suis dit ok
c'est la fréquentation de ruquier qui -
comme ça avance je l'aurais jamais dit
des trucs comme ça non mais dont on
parle le plus autour de vous les titien
son rapport de vous évidemment moi je
peux dire que j'en parle d'eux oui mais
bon il est excellent et 14 couverture de
magazine avec laetitia casta wicca tout
le monde parle d' astérix dans lequel on
va parler après il va jouer ça c'est
bien mais après ça près souvent montants
sont descendus donc c'était donc vous
avez l'impression qu'on parle de près en
ce moment à pierre arditi on parle
d'autre chose on les compare d'un jeu
choses sérieuses vont pas beaucoup du
discours dit sécuritaire cette fois elle
comment quand même fait face à la
violence urbaine avec les gens qui est
sauvageons théorie qui s'affrontent en
théorie qui consistera à envoyer ses
jeunes gens casser des cailloux et puis
d'autres qui pensent que peut-être il ya
d'autres moyens qu'on l'a fait du tout
préventif que maintenant il faut aussi
faire un peu du tout du tout du tout du
tout facile sanction est là je pense que
la vérité sur menthon d'âge entre les
deux alors on va commencer d'abord les
critères view voilà avec le leap airbus
de laetitia casta
donc vous avez apprises mais non
seulement appris j'ai inventé alors l
arrêt cassé
c'est l'hyper view la lumière change
comme ça évidemment avant on était 5
contre contre en la maintenant on est on
est plus 4 contre tout contre tout
contre
alors vous avez déclaré laetitia casta
j'aime pas la télé et surtout j'aimerais
pas en faire pourquoi vous trouvez ça
frelaté la télé vous trouvez que c'est
un monde on n'est pas naturel en
télévision alors je vais être très
naturel ouais mais j'essaye mais c'est
pas évident parce que faut aller vite
qu'une chose à dire et parfois on vous
coupe des salaires j'avais du mal à
poser leur jeu les jeunes m'a fait des
compliments sur l'aphasie plus cher
c'est ça vous avez l'impression que ça
va très vite que c'est ben oui mais nous
on est vous savez on ne fait pas marrer
on préférerait aller au bout des
problèmes en parler vraiment et tout
mais voilà les gens s'ennuient zappé
c'est terrible c'est ça qui vous énerve
à la télé c'est le zapping meja papa qui
a pu beaucoup si cela nous a un copain
un papa un papa qui appuie beaucoup sur
la télécommande
exactement oui alors vous avez 20 ans on
dit que vous êtes la plus belle femme du
monde c'est pas juste pour vous flatter
parce que c'est je le lis toute la
journée dans les journaux ils ont un
petit peu exagéré
ah bon ouais c'est fed allait voyager un
petit peu de plus belle femme du monde
voilà ma foi même nom mais d'autres
planètes vous savez exactement fallen
earth est d'accord pas pour moi il ya
juste une question c'est très très
personnel dans certains articles que
j'ai dit sur vous vous faites 88 60 88
et avant c'était 90 60 88 ça te dit rien
toi c'est bien pour mon auto mais c'est
un peu trop 8 60 88 ou 90 60 90 alors
franchement 90 60
d'accord c'est s'allongent se sont
trompés ils se centrant pour sony tels
son nom s'affiche pas du tout va alors
que nous étions
bon tu l'as cherché celle là tu sais que
tu vas chercher celle là qu'est ce que
je veux dire par est ce que je veux dire
par là c'est que on se fout des
mensurations voit qu'elle est belle on
n'a pas besoin de savoir combien à une
mesure de taille de tour de poitrine et
vous pas juré un message vous d'accord
vous savez sur 1 m non non pas des
paracels bon alors voulait dire quelque
chose votre laetitia casta non plus par
les gardes du corps et je parle comme
j'ai envie de parler je trouve que de
toute façon elle est très jolie qu'on
n'a pas besoin de savoir combien mesure
quoique je veux dire c'est c'est un
constat et les mails voilà qui file à
trouver non pas du tout vous êtes sur
une stèle et on vous admire
voilà alors non un mètre soixante et
onze pour les défilés sont en béton
c'est pas vrai je fais par notre santé
on vous fait combien m 68 et les petits
talons l'a68 bon vous êtes en tous les
cas pas c'est vrai enfin monsieur
monsieur plus que monsieur gros nous en
parlons tout à l'heure surtout plus est
un professeur très sérieux d'ailleurs
mon avis les partis maintenant depuis
cinq ans ou de chagall depuis le début
de l'an sion si le mec est encore là
quand il doit passer moi je dis bravo
il s'appelle flück depuis qu'il est tout
petit sens voulu c'est comme vous ok mon
prénom c'est votre vrai nom tandis que
voire dix ans il abat non moi je dirais
bien on sait ce que ça veut dire tu en
penses à laetitia casta ce que ça veut
dire en fait ce que ça signifie et ça
lui va très bien en plus vous n'êtes pas
latinistes pierre
je l'étais weecast à casta casta ces
chastes et lætitia c'est la joie ce son
nom signifie joie chaste en plus c'est
merveilleux je sais mais c'est vrai nom
alors été d'abord les joyeuses et elle
est chaste elle a fait ses études à les
arrêter cette étude 10 des ports donc
c'est normal le latin a pas vraiment eu
le temps
j'avais même si on va jusqu'à 25 ans
fait pas beaucoup de la tonne on m'avait
on en avait parlé
oui c'est ça c'est laetitia le biogaz
bourg aussi alors quand leur sang fait
mal et nous fait elle est née en
normandie mais elle a été levée en corse
et elle adore la corse
voilà c'est ça l'accord la force et la
raison alors là vous convenez commencé
dans le boulot on va pas raconter toute
votre carrière parce que mais vous allez
dis vous avez refusé la chirurgie
esthétique et vous avez dit pas question
qu'on touche à mes dents se jouera
surtout si c'est pas à vos dents qu'on a
envie de toucher tout de suite c'est du
routier c'est du rugby à la cdu était
entier c'est pas du tout
alors donc vous avez dit pas question
qu'on touche à mes dents parce que je
pense que ce serait la pire des insultes
à faire mes parents ouais ça suffit
comme ça à celles qui voulaient sans
payer non mais ce sont des vrais justin
sont bien réels sombre histoire elles
sont pas parfaites mais ça sert à quoi
l'être parfait ça c'est ici à canon mais
c'est vrai j'ai dit tous les jours
non ça sert à rien parce qu'on ressemble
à tout le monde après et j'ai pas envie
de ressembler à tout ça c'est réussi
j'ai envie d'être moi même simplement et
d'être heureuse voilà alors votre
première photo vous étiez c'était pour
le glamour italien vous avez une photo
adam et eve
au début comme sa seconde sous dit la
télé ça un peu frelaté toutefois
l'évident faut pour faire l'intéressant
et c'est vrai mais dans le monde de la
mode si c'est terrible quand vous avez
fait votre photo en adam et eve la
première fois ça devait être c'était pas
évident parce qu'il y avait un jeune
homme en face de moi qui dit adam giza
dents
est-ce qu'il était dur de la faille
sûrement et alors et donc
c'est pas évident quand on n'a pas
l'habitude de se mettre contre un jeune
homme parce que non mais c'est vrai et
j'avais les cheveux longs et j'avais que
les cheveux entre avec les chantres
premier vous et je me souvienne demandé
de me rapprocher 10 et j'étais comme ça
quand je rentrais levante puis voilà ça
c'est alors c'est une jolie avant tout
cas c'est une superbe et et adore mais
alors bon après il ya eu toute venue
d'un mode carrière ce qui était assez
drôle c'est la première fois vous avez
fait un défilé c'était pour gauthier
quand vous êtes arrivé vous à vis des
banques avec des cheveux rouges et vous
avez votre agent une sauce est vraiment
là je bosse mais c'est en fait sortait
l'école et j'ai encore mon cartable
on arrive au castillet avec mon père
m'accompagne à chaque fois et donc il
m'a dit matt en dehors je monte
j'arrive erin que comme ça a été mais je
retrouve des anneaux partout je vais
t'emmener au milieu wade s est donc
julie mais mince ils sont sympas ces
gens mais est ce que c'est la joie m
je redescends jeune papa tu calcules
agence je crois qu'on s'est trompé et me
faire appel non non non c'est ici j'y
retourne en fait
gauthier vous avez choisi justement
parce que vous ne ressemblez pas aux
autres en fait c'est ça l'histoire pour
lui poser des questions internes mois de
mai on avait l'habitude ces dernières
années d'avoir ce qui affecte par
exemple que envie de faire ça dans la
vie voilà qu'est ce que je vais rarement
c'est arrivé c'est quoi le désir de
départ c'est quoi c'est arrivé par
hasard par hasard c'est en vacances en
corse on est venu me voir et j'étais à
l'école j'étais petite fille c est
toujours dit toujours les nuages
mon frère travaille très bien à l'école
toujours premier de la classe et moi je
récupérer ses professeurs le professeur
dit midi donc c'est pas normal que t'es
pas comme ton frère toi alors
j'avais un peu de mal à suivre c'est
vrai et je tout le temps en train amusé
dehors à faire un petit truc et on m'a
proposé de faire ce métier je savais pas
du tout ce que c'était donc le mercredi
et le week-end après lé coach comme
faire des photos et ça m'a passionné
tête devant la caméra
tout arrive j'ai très bien devant la
photo parce que ça me prenait tout de
suite la pause vous savez tout très bien
notre sol ouais je m'amuse beaucoup
parce que ça me permet d'être quelqu'un
d'autre d'être par exemple une femme que
le fossat grave que je sois et ça m'a
permis de m'exprimer à ma façon
simplement des maîtres photographier
soit en allemand laeticia je le dis hein
laetitia n'aime pas être photographiée
quand elle travaille pas sûr si vous
passez un week-end avec laeticia que
vous la photographier sans arrêt savall
énervé je le dis à nos amis
c'est juste que ça m'intimide un peu
voilà parce qu'en franche-comté le
travail et des biens de photographies
dessins dit que tu aimes si jouer
finalement attendait la pierre boulât
tutoyer c'est parce que la vente
je pense tu sois quand j'aime bien
quelqu'un je tutoie parce que je me sens
à l'aise si je me sens pas à l'aise je
vais vous voyez vous êtes autant amusé à
faire du cinéma autant amusé qu'à faire
des photos lorsque je pense que tout en
nettement je pense que tout le monde
rêve de faire du cinéma puisque c'est un
métier extraordinaire et ça m'a permis
d'apprendre beaucoup de choses surtout
sur moi même
wei par exemple par exemple quand on
doit dire quelque chose à quelqu'un ou
je t'aime vraiment le ressentir donc à
ce moment là on pense à ce qu'on a fait
avant quand on m'a dit je t'aime on
ressent vraiment les choses on se
comprend un petit peu plus je trouve
c'est comme à moi je pense que c'est
comme un une armoire où il ya plusieurs
tiroirs on tire le rire on tire
en fait j'ai toujours fait ce qu'elle
veut ce qui est en train de dire là
c'est vachement bien
elle le sait pas utile je sais pas mais
en fait ce que tu en train de dire c'est
ce que disent taille 7 stanislavski
c'est à dire qu'il faut servi à
l'intérieur de soi ouvre les tiroirs
l'inter de soi pour mater tiroir au
service de quelqu'un qui n'est pas elle
fait du stand ce qui semble à moi voilà
aurez la chance parce que sur astérix
edge ou falbala donc c'est depardieu
c'est ça qui est amoureux d'elle alors
que arielle dombasle qui est sur le même
film ces cimetières beaucoup ciao bye
j'imagine j'imagine bien j'ai un sur
deux trois questions
bon je sais que vous êtes très discrète
sur votre vie privée vous avez raison
moi aussi vous vous non on sait deux
choses en fait vous ça vaut mieux on ces
deux choses on sait quand vous étiez
petit vous aviez des posteurs de bruel
sur vos murs et c'est toujours le cas
non d'accord non mais je signale obispo
aujourd'hui non plus mais ce que je dis
mais ce que je sais tu es ma génération
oui et c'est quelqu'un très mignon et je
chantais bien écrit et bien vous savez
quoi damian
c'est la deuxième chose c'est encore
plus surprenant parce que bruel c'est
vrai qu'à votre époque et plein de
jeunes filles des posteurs de de bruit à
l'époque la pizza pino
mais il ya quand même quand il avait des
rêves à pizza pino penser à bouffer
votre homme idéal je sais pas si c'est
toujours le cas parce que sinon alors là
on est tous morts
votre mii des halles ça serait jacques
brel lui aussi les morts c'est une
tragédie ça vous ai dit ça dans une
interview ah bon mais ça me rassure voir
pierre bachelet qui fait naître chez moi
qui fais mais je laisserai à personne
j'ai encore beaucoup de choses à
apprendre et pour dire mon ami des as et
un peu trop c'est un peu trop facile
justement je pense que je recherche pas
l'ami des halles je tourne à une chance
moi je n'ai jamais eu à manger lui qui
s'est tout simplement quelqu'un de vrai
et quelqu'un qui soit lui-même et qu'il
soit sincère
bon voilà leurs amis au revoir c'était
tout le monde en parle
rendez-vous dans quinze jours bon alors
non alors voilà dernière chose vous vous
dites pas ce que c'est on sait
évidemment on se demande quand on voit
quelqu'un comme vous comment est ce que
on pourrait la séduit enfin la limite
d'âge est dépassé mais je parle pour des
gens comme laurent qui sont à la fois ça
y est ça l est en train de marge en la
france le roc est dans la force de l'âge
vous vous dites comme j'aime pas les
boîtes et voilà c'est terrible parce que
vous dites je suis un peu mémère ça veut
dire des discothèques
on n'aime pas les discothèques elle dit
je suis un peu mémère ça veut dire quoi
je suis jamais de seul je suis un peu
ennuyeuse vous dit c'est vous qui le
dites j'aime pas aller en boîte parce
que je trouve que j'aime bien danser je
trouve pas qu'on boiton prises dans
c'est vraiment ouais parce que l'on se
fait marcher sur les pieds et la fumée
de cigarette on a mal aux yeux dans les
yeux gonflés comme ça moi je trouve pas
ça demain je préfère danser chez moi ou
les boîtes déjà seynoise et ne souhaite
pas qu'on puisse rencontrer quelqu'un
s'en fout dans le noir quoi ouais
bombay très bien non vous puis pour
finir vous avez dit que je suis stupide
parfois un peu bête en larges crochets
de la fausse modestie parce que le
discours que vous tenez là depuis un
moment c'est prouvé tout à fait le
contraire
simplement parce que je pense qu'il faut
remarquer quand même et pendant un temps
tous les top models les mannequins
étaient assez avc tip toe le look
anorexiques bien sûr c'était tweedy et
kate moss va pas d'un seul coup on a une
jeune femme très vrai avec des rondeurs
qui est ce que les femmes peuvent
s'identifier à elle qu'est ce que vous
voulez qu'on s'identifie et kate moss
moi je veux bien mais on en voit là on
n'en voit pas tous les jours et
renversant vraiment quand on vous a
proposé l'astérix vous croyez que c'est
ce qui s'est passé en corse tout ce que
vous avez dit oui vous et daisy vie je
n'ai pas joué
et en fait ça s'est bien passé c'est
plutôt une récré pour vous des conneries
depardieu était sympa avec très
sympathique parce que ils ont pas mis de
barrière justement s'attaquer à la
mannequin assez pour jouer et non au
contraire ils ont ouvert les portes et
ça m'a beaucoup touché
moi je regarde toi un bon esprit non
dans des signes comme ça non les gens
ont envie de passer un moment ça qu'ils
vont passer trois mois ensemble ils
veulent que ce soit grave principe oui
oui oui qui vous a fait le plus rire sim
depardieu clavier
michel galabru j'avoue que si n'ya pas
de mal gérard c'est surtout moi ce qui
m'a beaucoup touché ses premiers jours
bon après c'est le tournage mais est ce
qu'il a fait pour jour c'était assez
drôle
gérard depardieu est ce qu'il a fait
c'est la belle était lui même est arrivé
vers moi et il est arrivé en caleçon
avec des bottes le malin non mais moi
j'aime les gens qui sont naturels voilà
tout ce qu'a indiqué juste une question
comme ça vous n'êtes pas dans le non dit
xhafa sais que ça vous estival à au
moins je suis pas mal alors mesdames
messieurs sur la libye un film il ya pas
pierre arditi et bien aller voir mes dit
allez-y précipité obélix et astérix
contre césar merci beaucoup laetitia de
votre franchise dans tous les cas on va
regarder un extrait regardez la bande
annonce du film
[Musique]
je n'ai pas pu
ah ah
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le bras
c'est compliqué mais fêtant sa saison
du temps il
que sont à présent
je vais faire ce qu'on est
[Musique]
m
et
obélix à chaque fois
[Musique]
voilà alors astérix contre césar 17 ans
contre césar jean pierre arditi me
disais que c'était bien foutu il parlait
pas de laetitia casta
il parlait du film qu'on va continuer
notre débat qui est la femme idéale de
l'an 2000 or nous on a déjà notre petite
idée mais on a demandé à des
spécialistes leur avis alors
jean-françois janval bonsoir bonsoir ces
photographes vous avez fait un bouquin
qui s'appelle balcon alors on comprend
tout de suite il ya du monde au balcon
il ya du monde au balcon c'est sûr avec
la dga sont donc ces dvd est ce que tu
en seras hicquebrant sinon c'est pas sûr
mike bray que ma qualité beaux balcons
aussi mais est tombé du balcon
donc c'est chez ipso facto alors qu'il
n'ya pas laetitia casta dans ce bouquin
mais non là on a voulu faire des
actrices on devenir enfin c'est un mot à
la mode peut-être mais des actrices
comme ça bon on aurait pu en prendre
plein d'autres c'est sur l'ailleurs
n'arrose ouais on aurait pu comprendre
au moins quinze vingt quand je sais pas
mais je vais faire un autre bouquin dira
peut-être un balcon bis un balcon terre
enfin alors docteur gros alors vous vous
êtes sinologue alors j'ai publié un
bouquin on s'était vus à l'époque
d'embellie comprend réalisé sympa
l'étude de la sénilité
non non compris donc si vous avez des
choses à dire michel aulas je vais faire
beaucoup en 87 qui s'appelait le sein
dévoilé comme ça quand c'était connu
dans bad minuit veut le faire était
sénologue lui dessiner c'est pour ça
qu'ils vont quand ils vous regardent
c'est pas de la concupiscence essai
professionnel c'est un examen donc vous
vous êtes dans votre père charles gros
l'été le premier sénologue et vous vous
êtes deuxième c'est noël dans votre
boulot c'est bien ce qu'on a c'est de
toucher des dessins il ya que deux
synagogues en france
bah oui
bien sûr il a beaucoup d'autres il
fallait individualisés et une médecine
du sahel c'est quelque chose de très
important très très qui malheureusement
est touchée souvent par la maladie donc
petit être qu'est ce que les dons vous
touchez des symptômes est ce que les
maris viennent par exemple est ce que
les titres quand ils envoient leurs
femmes chez le senior est ce qu'ils
viennent avec leurs fans
il ya une chose très spécifique à la
médecine des saints c'est que il ya un
accompagnement très important les les
femmes viennent souvent avec l'or alors
marie leur fils hamed bouzzine parce que
je sais c'est que c'est vraiment le lien
certain que vous iriez avec votre femme
si elle allait chez le docteur royal est
tout seul c'est le sénat débat oui bien
sûr
est-ce que votre femme vous avez vous
accompagne celle couillaud lot alors
dites moi avant de passer ce que la
femme de pierre hardy qui a besoin d'un
décès n'a pas du tout jetable et la
femme de terabithia la panique on ne
sait pas j'avais dit mois avant de
passer tout fameux docteur plus qu
est-ce qu est-ce que vous pouvez nous
expliquer juste en un mot c'est un mot
que vous qui aimez bien les mots tiens
l'érythème pudique américain pudique
c'est quelque chose qu'on observe assez
fréquemment lorsque la femme vient en
consultation est obligé de dévoiler ses
seins il ya ce phénomène donc de pudeur
qui fait qu elle rougit dans cette
partie au dessus des saints est souvent
sur les seins donc c'est ce qu'on
appelle l'érythème public
je ne savais pas ça par contre je crois
savoir que vous avez vous avez toute une
théorie sur le sein justement non
seulement mais pas seulement son
entraîneur veut que votre idée en fait
c'est de montrer que les modes dessin on
sait que comme thierry disais tout à
l'heure en 77 et twiggy plus de ça on
vous laisse et soutien gorge et c'est
que maintenant à priori c'est un retour
aux femmes pulpeuses avec des seins
généreux et tout ça et vous êtes vous
vous avez un peu démontré qu'en fait le
saint c'est ça suis vraiment évolution
de la société c'était un peu ça votre
discours russe et c'est un bon reflet
culturel mais je lirai au préalable que
un peu comme il est là quand la famille
dg la femme à carantec n'existe pas
ajouté d'ailleurs c'est pas ma faute
c'est de moi qui l'aï inventé mais nous
en tant que médecin ce qu'on voit c'est
c'est pas des la femme collective c'est
des personnes individuelles oui donc et
on remarque que chaque femme un idéal et
qui lui est propre en idéal du sein qui
lui est propre et qui dépendent de ceux
de sa personne elle même de son histoire
de son conjoint
le corse embellie sous le regard de
l'homme qui vous aime a donc il ya
beaucoup de choses qui l'interviewent
gros m'a raconté en coulisses tout à
l'heure un cas d'une femme qui avait le
sein gauche qui pendait plus que c'est
un droit
elle était persuadée que c'était parce
que son mari lui tenait toujours ce
salah pendant qu'elle dormait et est ce
que c'est alors qu'est ce
milton keynes en école de chant répondu
mais est ce que vous faites chantera pas
une chose aisée
une chose est vraie c'est qu' il n'y a
jamais un st droit et gauche tout à fait
identique servi en volume bien sûr je
dirais souvent comme il ya certaines
femmes qui ont un simple plus sensible
que l'autre eh bien ils ont parfois
tendance à se laisser caresser celui qui
leur donne le ton alors justement nous
années merci docteur go nous en étions à
docteur fugue
alors vous avez écrit un bouquin qui
s'appelle la beauté tout un art qui est
publié aux éditions asiad alors vous
êtes chirurgien esthétique vous avez
énormément de succès pour une raison
très simple en fait et quand on le sait
on comprend c'est qu'en fait plutôt que
de faire des visages des corps tous sur
le même modèle
vous êtes plutôt un esthète on peut le
dire et vous intéresser beaucoup à la
beauté au tableau la beauté à travers
les âges et c est quand vous faites un
camp vous réparez quelqu'un enfin quand
vous quand vous corrigez quelqu'un dise
on vous le fait non pas selon enfin vous
faites à des panels anderson à la chaîne
voilà ce qu'on peut dire pour aller plus
vite
alors est-ce que la beauté à ses lois
est ce que la beauté peut être mise en
équation
alors effectivement dans qu'il existe je
dirais des normes universelles de la
bouteille
ça a été démontré à travers tous les
âges et toutes les époques et je pense
que ces règles sont quelquefois utile
pour un chirurgien esthétique comme la
série donc j'ai pu rallier où je voulais
justement démontré ce rapport entre
entre l'art l'esthétique et la chirurgie
esthétique
alors j'ai lu un j'ai lu un papier de
vous dans le figaro magazine nous
expliquer que laetitia casta
correspondait à peu près ou complètement
derrière vous je peux être disgracieux
et vous aux canons de la beauté c'est à
dire par exemple il ya des règles que
moi je ne connais pas du tout des
travaux clair que je vais rencontrer une
fille je vais regarder
il faut que le tour de taille soit
toujours inférieurs d'un tiers au tour
de hanche
et ça il faut avoir fait math spé un
jour quelqu un m outre hama des cas de
gêne un peu sinon mais ça ça remonte à
temps des docteurs des normes sociales
on a appris ça ce sont des normes
universelles qui ont été décrites par
léonard de vinci
ouais lorsqu'il a illustré un livre qui
a été écrit par un moine frappe at you
li di borgo c'était un 15 109 et là il
avait donc défini la règle d'or
ouais et la règle d'or est devenu par la
suite lorsque ça a été repris par un
ingénieur roumain le nombre d'or et ce
fameux nombre d'or on le retrouve dans
toute sorte de monument que ce soit en
architecture dans les beaux-arts dans la
peinture et c'est valable aussi pour le
corps humain parce que ça a été
largement étudiés donc soit ce rapport à
votre l'alliance le tour de hanche et le
tour de taille
oui il est allemand il devrait se situer
dans un nombre qui est très voilà alors
je le dis aux téléspectateurs après
l'émission vous pouvez prendre un
centimètre il faut que le tour de taille
souhaite toujours inférieurs d'un tiers
au tour de hanches voulait jamais fait
ce test là vous mais vous l'avez dit
alors tu sois sage tout à l'heure tout à
l'heure vous avez donné les donc je vous
écoute est tout à l'heure vous avez
donné les chiffres de moi ici à des
mensurations idéales 90 60 88
ben si vous divisez 60 par 88 vous
arrivez à 0.6 sénardes voilà donc
maintenant la dernière chez moi ça me
passionne les pupilles dilatées aussi
moi je crois qu'on avait les pupilles
dilatées canton se défoncer il paraît
que les gens qu'on les pupilles plus 10
des ventes vous parlez de votre
expérience voilà si j'étais tout seul il
pareil guigou aussi
si vous aussi d'autres la ministre qui a
dit qu'elle fumer des pétards maintenant
on peut le dire quand se fait dominique
voynet qui a dit ça bigou si jeudi vous
aussi vous êtes sûr de sa belle ne s'est
pas tu m'appelles tu me dis ce sétois
doivent aller c'est normal pour la
circulation alternée les frères el rhoul
les jours bravo les pupilles dilatées
les gens qu'on les pupilles dilatées il
paraît qu'ils sont plus attirants que
les autres
ça a été ça a été prouvé étudier parce
que les scientifiques en fait des études
là dessus si on présente des photos
d'une même personne d'une femme mais
avec pupilles dilatées ou pilleurs et
racler tous ceux qui ont dû faire leur
choix entre les photos ont choisi la
friterie danger qui est ici ça c'est pas
seulement en football dans le monde
entier les hommes préfèrent donc voilà
mesdames faites vous dilater les
pupilles chargé d'âmes n'écoutez pas
tout ça veut strictement rien dire le
charme d'une femme n'est absolument pas
se passe absolument vous générez avait
été moi des fois j'ai pourtant je n'aime
pas faim sexuellement les femmes
mais quand je marche dans la rue je vois
une belle femme mais je la regarde elle
n'est pas forcément parfaitement
contraire parce qu'elle a un truc de
différent là un truc de mystère et c'est
en elle c'est un truc qu'elle dégage
bougies mathématiques
c'est quoi ce lynchage de l'animateur
c'est quoi cette émission on loge est
entièrement d'accord avec vous ce que
vous d'élire la caisse que changeriez
chez laetitia casta si vous l'aviez sur
votre bistouri sûrement rien du tout
puisque en gelée décrite comme idéale là
d'accord mais vous alors se changer et
des tas de choses chez les autres mais
votre nom il y avait jamais sans dire
comment on dit on des poules comme si
vous n'arrivez pas à prononcer le paie
parce que c'est un endroit consonance
allemande il faut dire foule qui oublié
le pays vous d'être très bien alors
maintenant est ce qu'on peut faire venir
on a deux trois témoignages j'aimerais
bien qu'on l'a kiki qui viennent nous
voir
je crois que stéphanie bibard alors
stéphanie lui c'est incroyable parce que
vous et vous mademoiselle vous êtes
aurélie alors vous relie pluvinage c'est
ça bon alors là voilà deux exemples
absolument tête vous n'êtes pas très
fourni de ce côté là mais très joli et
fuselées pas de ça ne vous en foutez
alors que stéphanie bibard qui a fait
beaucoup de couvertures on l'a vu dans
pas mal de couvertures de journaux vous
en faites vous êtes souvent demandés
pour vous ça qu'on appelle le mannequin
ça entre autres oui oui oui pour la
lingerie pour des photos de nu mais
beauté bien sûr et
j'ai la chance d'avoir naturellement
j'apprécie nature oui naturellement
pensé naturellement c'est naturellement
craquant mais parce que je peux pas me
servir demain parce que si je me serre
des mains en europe varie pas mal du
tout la vie collective a pu être mis en
valeur
simplement donc c'est vrai que je suis
assez gêné tournée je vais donc vous en
fait vivent et de sa bulle et de ce à
quoi quand on a quand une boîte de
lingerie fait des pubs c'est vous qui
s'appelle beaucoup d'argent et vous avez
quand même un joli découvert et vous
alors aurélie ça vous gêne pas de nom
les hommes dont vous n'avez pas touché
jamais personne ne s'est plaint allongé
mais bon ce sont différents en temps je
suis petit j'ai rien dis toujours dit
est-ce que patricia est ce que vous nous
présentez le premier à votre gauche vous
avec a beaucoup moins de 5 le retrouve
pas sa surprise avec ce à commencer par
les jeunes femmes vous avez christelle
qui elle est mannequin pour les jambes
ça vous serez intéressant de montrer ce
qui peut être un peu les jambes idéale
aujourd'hui puisqu'elle travaille
beaucoup pour ces gens on mesure combien
vos jambes je crois à m'être dit ouais
j'ai deux points de karembeu quand même
hein mais là le record du monde termine
3 mais vous ne vous êtes pas très loin
je suis joe diop sa très lourde à 10 cm
non mais c est vous vous travaillez vous
c'est les jambes principalement pour les
jambes
donc si on avait vos jambes à vous
laisse 1 2
bibard et cela ferait un accord de
quelqu'un pour faire un nom mais
attention moi j'utilise la poitrine pour
effectivement mais j'utilise énormément
mon visage mon corps et moi j'utilise
les fesses yannick alors qu'il ya nick
lui vous allez bien les choses qui
étaient alors lycéen fou de femmes c'est
un fou de ces infos de gros seins aussi
donc voilà c'est yannick sûr que vous en
faites votre problème que la finition
soignée
voilà si vous changez en insistant que
la vie soit la fille soit bien pas bien
et où du moment que l'adc non pas faut
pas non plus n'ont pas non plus déconner
mais c'est vrai que une certaine on se
dira profusion ma mère ne me dérange
absolument pas oui c'est pas c'est votre
truc que j'aime bien car dit-il ça vous
fait quoi que c'est moi vous en vivez
non c'est son truc assez classique dont
vous n'êtes pas parce que vous aimez là
mais dès sa sortie ça paye sa cinéaste
qui en vie et qui quittent au meilleur
du temps meilleurs cafés les mégapixels
et bertrand blier qui a fait aussi un
livre un livre sur les aspects deux
cinéastes en ville ce sont les
soutiens-gorge bertrand membre
merci à tous merci docteur merci merci
stéphanie donc où est passée la provoc
avec christine boutin 15-0 thierry
feaster guy konopnicki et laurent alliez
mais avant tout cette émission
maintenant on n'est plus proposé
uniquement que de débat il ya aussi des
interviews qu on appelle des hyper view
ah oui c'est apprendre c'est un procès
politique et j'appelle donc christine
boutin bonsoir christine boutin ne soyez
pas trop vous n'êtes pas impressionné
par cet aéropage entre vous hyper view
mais non j'ai dit qu'on 60 contraire
c'est que 5 contre 1 dans un langage
argotique c'est la masturbation
vous saviez absolument pas mais je
conçois laurent rue kennedy caste il va
vous des scellés alors vous êtes mariés
vous avez trois enfants vous êtes donc
un peu en france la personne qui défend
des la famille vous êtes fondatrice de
l'alliance pour le droit à la vie c'est
ça pour les droits de la vie et les
droits de la vie et vous êtes lié à
l'association pour la promotion de la
famille
pardon l'association pour la promotion
de la famille non non j'ai pas de
l'union pantalonnade
c'est une association familiale elle
existe cette association at il imagé
pallier à cette association ce qui peut
rien c'est et de l'association et les
revoir madame
vous êtes laverie christine boutin ah
ben c'est ce que vous êtes bien
consulteurs pontificale sur la famille
au vatican c'est vrai j'ai consulté un
pendentif ical au conseil pontifical
pour la famille oui bon quand vous dites
que vous avez de la compassion pour les
homosexuels est ce que vous trouvez pas
que finalement c'est une attitude un peu
condescendante sait comment est la
compassion pour des infirmes pour des
malades ne peut être ai je dit que
j'avais la compassion je ne suis pas sûr
d'avoir employé ce terme ce que je pense
ce que je sais vis-à-vis des personnes
homosexuelles et comme vis-à-vis de
toute personne quel que soit son état de
santé sa race ou sa religion chez de
l'amour pour toutes personnes que je
rencontre
parce que pour moi toute personne est à
l'image de dieu je peux poser une
question parce que c'est vrai je vous ai
déjà reçu sur inter cette semaine et
mais une question que je ne vous ai pas
posé on avait tourné à tous remarqué que
vous ne dites jamais les homosexuels
mais les personnes homosexuelles
pourquoi qu'il ya différents c'est parce
que les personnes de petite taille les
personnes de couleur
parce que avant tout pour moi la dignité
vient à la personne et non pas en
fonction de son comportement son choix
politiques ou tard a sauté religion
c'est d'abord une personne et par le
fait que j'indique personnes
homosexuelles et bien c'est pour moi un
jeune homosexuel c'est pas votre non pas
du tout une située à cette espèce et 1
et ainsi tester notre subconscient qui
parle j'en sais rien comme chez mon
subconscient qui parle comme le vôtre
oui l'homosexuel suis pas sûr qu'ils
peuvent aussi parlantes ou
l'homosexualité rendre de plus en plus
dans la vie courante aujourd'hui à peu
près sur dix films qui sortent au cinéma
en ce moment une a5 qui sont consacrés à
l'homosexualité 5 qui sont consacrés à
l'homosexualité féminine
la plupart des gens maintenant qu'ils
sont homosexuels le disent beaucoup de
gens par exemple c'est très bien je vais
vous montrer un petit bout de clips la
judge michael qui est un chanteur bien
connu il a été attrapé dans les
toilettes
hollywood et non pas voir ça c'est trash
et cette histoire me dit tout de suite
j'aimerai parce que la mission pour un
temps à voir le clip qu'il l'a fait
parce que au lieu au lieu de se doucher
pas dessous cachés au lieu de il a dit
ben oui c'est vrai et il a fait un clip
on va avoir un petit bouquet après on
continuera
[Musique]
et
pour vous
[Musique]
un beau rebond encore nous ils plongent
à tournai
[Musique]
toronto
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
chabran
oui
[Musique]
je suis fou
faux
on vous
voilà c'est le dernier clip de george
michael alors ce que je veux dire en
montrant ça c'est que finalement
maintenant voilà quoi avant on se
souvient dans le temps quand les
chanteurs étaient homosexuels ne disait
pas c'était secret ça se raconte et
maintenant voilà et on la trappe dans
les toilettes et il fait un clip audio
oui je suis homosexuel donc est ce que
vous pensez pas par rapport à ça que
finalement c'est quelque chose qui est
passé dans les moeurs pour qu'on n'y
peut pas grand chose finalement que que
je ne crois pas que ce soit complètement
passées dans les moeurs je pense qu'il
ya encore beaucoup de chemin à faire
pour que ça passe dans les moeurs
du reste vous donner l'exemple d'un
chanteur mais moi j'entends dans le
monde politique
beaucoup des personnes de la communauté
homosexuelle reproche que les hommes
politiques vous paraît-il il ya beaucoup
d'homosexuels paraît-il il y en a très
peu qui affirment qu'ils osent l'affirmé
et regardez par exemple monsieur
labarrère qui l'a dit depuis fort
longtemps et tout à fait respectable et
admirable pour finalement assène me pose
personnellement aucun problème dans ce
qu'il faut dire c'est quand même qu'il
ya très peu de gens en tout cas en
france qui le disent qu'ils l'ont dit et
on peut le comprendre on n'a pas les
blâmer je trouve ça ferait d'ailleurs
qu'en face ce qu'on appelle je crois de
de la outings celles fonctionnant au
gène ans 4 c'est un choix c'est à chacun
de dire s'il a envie de le dire mais il
faut surtout préciser que c'est beaucoup
plus facile à dire quand on est un peu
connus ou célèbres comme la haye de
george michael est évidemment que je
fais partie de la bonne bourgeoisie
bordelaise pas exactement son entourage
ne permettrait probablement pas que la
personne n'y a pas je peux l'avoir
choisie parce que dans les milieux
on choisit ses yeux dans les milieux
populaires ce n'est pas non plus une
chose que l'on dit facile en évidence ce
village neuf dixièmes que jeudi le
ministre c'est quand même beaucoup plus
compliqué pour quelqu'un qui est
tourneur dans une usine d'exprimer sa
ses larmes en face à son entourage que
par rapport à un chanteur à succès
acquis toute façon sera protégé par sa
notoriété
je vais vous dire quand vous grandissez
la bible quand vous grandissez la bible
la bible ce infernale comme la bible
c'est des sodomites ya beaucoup ilyasova
mégots mort il ya de l'inceste
quand la fille aînée de lot torche son
père pour qu'il la saute c'est vraiment
la génèse 19 jeunesse je n'ai pas dit
que c'est simple je préfère le prince
d'égypte moi je n'aime pas mais ça vous
le savez vu ça absolument pas alors suis
pas là considéré jusque là filles de
loth à fille aînée de lot fait boire son
père et son père lui fait un enfant et
les prêts ça recommence avec la salomon
polygamie 1000 femmes les maris marié à
12 ans lorsque je veux dire c'est que
c'est avec comportements humains qui
sont rapportés dans la bible mais en ce
qui concerne la bim
je peux malheureusement moi je n'ai pas
préparé comme vous et je ne peux pas
vous donner la bbc mais bon c'est mon
sac et dans la loge messieurs
mais je suis désolé mais on table et me
chercher en irak la bible et dans mon
sac à ce moment là je voudrais la
référence exacte c'est à la fois dans
l'ancien de nouveaux états membres
effectivement dit très clairement que
l'homosexualité n'est pas acceptable
oui enfin la cèze la polygamie tout ça
c'est l'enfant toute façon ce n'est pas
celui-là vous m'aviez posé la question
de savoir pourquoi j'avais montré cette
bible et bien j'avais mon j'ai montré
cette ville parce que c'est l ouvrage
que j'avais dans mon sac
madame guigou pour gagner du temps nous
lisez pour une deuxième fois le discours
que nous avons une heure plus tôt donc
moi j'ai essayé de lui donner d'autres
sujets de lecture ayant n'en a pas voulu
mais par contre monsieur h députés
communistes à lui lui a lu la bible
cantique des cantiques et l'ecclésiaste
à chaque personne que c'est un
communiste tout le monde trouve ça
normal
voilà les premiers à la fête de
l'humanité la prochaine fois vous savez
quel thème mêlera jésus on trouve ça
tout à fait normal
personne ne dit rien mais si vous
indique quelque chose parce que l'état
catholique parce qu'elle est catholique
pardonnez moi et bien à ce moment là ça
devient objet de scandale
c'est absolument le fait staline avec
devinez
mais moi je tue pas stalinien alors moi
je me demande au fond je vais vous dire
pourquoi vous a demandé de déplacer soit
parce qu'on va parler du consensus on a
parlé du politiquement correct on va
parler la provocation se demandant où
est passée la provocation
moi je me demande au fond si vous n'êtes
pas la dernière provocatrice parce que
finalement aujourd'hui tout le monde
pense à peu près la même chose et vous
vous arrivez à l'assemblée nationale
vous prenez la parole vous ai alors dit
encore plus provocatrice que ça ne vous
connaissez ce journal ça que je viens
vous vous avez donné c'est comme la
provocation ça dans un journal s'appelle
tabloïds qui est un journal biais
delà de la région avez vous tiré
maintenant je reçois battant je suis
abonné à temps ceddat région rhône alpes
c'est le journal gai de la région de la
région rhône alpes il ya un article qui
est en page 6 jeudi sa patricia voilà
qui s'appelle christine boutin j'aime le
sexe
moi je rencontre ça moi aussi j'adore le
sexe non mais voilà je montre à la
caméra
donc je sais pas est ce que vous vous
êtes une provocatrice tu sais par quoi
non mais c'est le jeu de façon vos
paroles vous en viager les miennes
engagé m'engage également
et quand j'ai accepté de faire de dans
une interview dans cette revue ugg et je
les fais parce que je n'ai pas de raison
de ne pas répondre à une demande d'une
revue gay pour préparer le pacs j'ai
rencontré la communauté homosexuelle
ce que j'ai dit c'est pas simplement
dans mon idée de leader et de
l'idéologie de dogmatisme
j'essaie d'être compétent des personnes
homosexuelles me demande une interview
je réponds alors ce que j'ai essayé de
la faire comprendre c'est que j'aime et
l'amour bien sûr et donc ça a été titré
j'aime le sexe bien trop c'est pas mal
mais pas contre toi merci ben voilà donc
maintenant on va passer à l'action a
vite à dîner mme boutin si on entame de
top ce que je veux faire un bouquet de
fleurs c'était toi je suis dit comme ça
se passe et elle va être va sûrement
pleurer pendant la mission et celle là
c'était de la passion c'était des larmes
c'était des larmes de crocodile j'ai été
profondément blessée est vrai absolument
j'estime que le premier ministre est la
question que je voulais lui poser en
décembre a du mal à vous croire que ça
vous c'est votre responsabilité est ce
que je peux vous dire c'est que j'ai été
blessé et je voulais demander au premier
ministre si véritablement c'était sa
façon de traiter les femmes ce qu'il
venait de faire devant l'ensemble de la
classe pilote j'étais loin des hommes
savaient mais vous savez bien que non
non c'est bien vous aviez que monsieur
je sais pas été un des premiers pays à
des blocs non c'est non même si c'est
maintenant notre sensibilité à vous vous
savez très bien que comme il l'a si bien
quand même le propre
avoir commencé à faire rentrer les
femmes la base et enfin sur dc on est
d'ailleurs tout de suite ce n'est pas je
suis pas béni oui oui on est très en
deçà de ce qu'il faudrait donc cesser de
rouler fort et je suis assez bien le
sujet ce match mais il est par ailleurs
encore beaucoup d'efforts à la parité
n'a pas dit où est justement que j'avais
pris un appareil qui est comment va
commerce à d'une femme debbie merci à
tous les à côtés les questions on va
avancer je suis désolé donc on passe au
débat donc on appelle toc chaude ils
deviendront choses encore pires à la
fois ci encore une chose je sais pas
vous dites que le premier ministre
une curiosité la manière dont on traite
un député moi il me semble en tout cas
qu'un certain nombre de vos collègues
députés ont une curieuse manière de
traiter les femmes dans l'hémicycle et
ça malheureusement ça se voit très
souvent la télévision c'est très bien
fait je suis bien placé dans le divorce
collègues ses collègues chinois monnaies
collègues bien l'autre côté
contrairement à ce que beaucoup de
femmes disent je dis qu'il est très
agréable est une femme en politique
parce que les hommes sont courtois bien
alors ça c'est celle là on passe alors
on passe vraiment au débat donc ça
s'appelle toqueshow les débats là non
alors ça s'appelle où est passée la
provo je vais recevoir d'abord karl zéro
et avant qu'il arrive pendant qu'il
arrive on va regarder un petit sujet qui
reprend ses meilleures questions
justement tu dis depuis toujours la
france marche au mélange
alors pour être un peu polémique je
dirais est ce que c'est pour ça que la
loi chevènement c'est un mélange de la
loi pasqua et la loi debré si d'aventuré
le mouvement des chômeurs dégénéré et
que le président chirac s'enfuit à baden
baden est ce que vous seriez prêt à
assumer le est ce que vous seriez prêt à
être président de la république
d'abord il ne peut ni rep à baden baden
baden baden n'y a plus rien bon vous
savez il n'est pas très bien informé on
l'a vu récemment coûté 40 0 voyant soyez
un peu plus aimable à l'égard du prélat
les mauvaises langues des ennemis disait
te définit c'est comme ça il disait un
tiers-mondiste deux tiers monde à ça
t'énerve où ça t'amuse finalement j'ai
lu quelque part que votre épouse et vous
possédiez un deux pièces rue de
vaugirard un trois-pièces rue pascal un
cinq pièces rue de navarre et un
six-pièces place du panthéon
alors la question c'est qu'est ce que
vous avez contre les 4 pièces
c'est un choix un choix d'abord je ne
l'est pas
moi je n'ai qu'un appartement place du
pin terre alors il paraît qu'à réaliser
ton rêve en octobre dernier
il ya un mois en allant aux états unis
c'est pas très très orthodoxe pour un
communiste d'aller au pays des yankees
impérialiste et les hyènes lubrique mais
jugez pas sur ce que disent les autres
jugés sur les faits et les actes
un grand journaliste comme vous de juger
sur les faits et les actes il doit pas
juger sur les intentions et sur les
remarques tout flatteur vit aux dépens
de ce noble sport
karl zéro bonsoir vous gardez votre
manette avec vous toujours comme ça va
il ya des documents qui te concerne donc
je vais sortir car le bras donc ça c'est
le vrai journal c'est le dimanche à
canal à 12h40 c'est demain voilà c'est
demain que je compte en clair il faut le
faut le dire en clair bien sûr c'est
très clair est-ce qu'on se souhaite vous
voyez là oh non moi je peux pas ah bon
c'est moi avant de tutoyer tout le monde
et toi tu tutoyer les tue vous voyez
puis maintenant on a interverti car
quand vous avez changé de look que vous
avez quitté votre jeans pour mettre un
costume cravate
vous avez déclaré maintenant on parle
différemment on me respecte et ça me
plaît est ce que c'est bien dans la
bouche d'un provocateur d'un impertinent
de s'habiller en costume cravate pour
qu'on le respecte
ballet au costume cravate en fait c est
intervenu très tôt un tu sais c'est je
te tue tout un radical on va se tuer des
voix et tu fais comme tu le sens c'est
intervenu en fait quand j'ai décidé que
je m'appelais karl zéro donc comme tout
le monde avait les cheveux longs et des
pantalons pattes d'eph
j'ai décidé que je m'appelais 4 0 que
j'étais punk et donc comme j'étais punk
je mettais un costume avec une cravate
en faire pour est habillé comme un
notaire de province tu vois dans les
années 50 c'était une c'était une forme
de révolte
évidemment après bon j'ai été rattrapée
puisque la jeune ba ouais et alors je
pourrais avoir les cheveux longs mais
j'ai plus de cheveux donc je reste comme
ça quoi alors tu as déclaré dans le
monde il ya trois sujets tabous sur
canal c'est le foot le cinéma et la cgu
alors cg il faut le dire c'est vivant
dit qui est propriétaire de canal
et puis si on n'est pas d'accord avec ça
il faut aller faire une télé pirate
bien sûr ça limite un peu nos ambitions
mais c'est comme ça partout moi au moins
j'ai le courage de le dire est ce que
c'est bien le digne d'un provocateur sa
de reconnaître qu'on n'a pas droit de
parler du psg attend du cinéma et 2
les 24 heures non mais le mot
provocateur ça n'a pas de sens
provocateur ça veut dire essayer de
provoquer quelque chose une réaction par
rapport à ce que voient les
téléspectateurs dans l'émission donc je
me définirais pas comme provocateur moi
j'essaye de dire la vérité ça c'est un
paramètre bon j'ai dit ce paramètre
alors en plus je l'avais dit comme ça ça
fait le gros titre dans le monde avant
de presser à boom boom sur ma tête on
m'a dit comment tu peux dire ça mais en
même temps bon c'était mieux de le dire
il vaut toujours mieux dire la vérité
c'est vous que c'est vous qui demandez
carlo aux invités politiques de vous
tutoyer vouloir les forcer avec une
foyer ne les force pas c'est à dire la
première fois on se vouvoie c'est très
respectueux n'est ce pas casting et à la
fin de la première interview jeudi
maintenant qu'on se connaisse la
lituanie tutoyait alors ils disent oui
ou non il y en a certains qu'on dit nous
et what i think accepte ça je lui dis
d'accord si on s'embrasse alors j'ai
appris qu'à cela tienne on s'est
embrassés 36 sec et alors tu avais un
début d'érection ça on avait dit qu'on
en parle est passé des choses hier dit
il vous fait rire il nous fait rire 15-0
donc
non il va crs voilà voilà
moi je trouve alors je sais que ça se
fait pas rire matin jetons le vrai
journal absolument formidable mais cette
attaque systématique anti le pen tous
les dimanches ça vous vous trouvez pas
que c'est un peut enfoncer des portes
ouvertes non non non je ne crois pas que
ce soit enfoncer des portes ouvertes
dont je crois pas qu'il ya des habitudes
à prendre avec sa voix toujours aussi le
troublant c'est toujours aussi moi ça me
perturbe toujours autant je n'ai pas
envie de m'habituer cette chose là ça
dépasse le début du roman en plus c'est
pas enfoncer des portes ouvertes parce
que c'est attractif front national sur
des trucs precinct dans la vieille dans
le cimetière qui disait mon mari a donné
son héritage à l'open hélas jamais
fleuri la tombe
c'était formidable écoute mais je dirai
ce que de la même les guignols karl tu
le sais même les guignols on fait un
sketch où quand on voit le front
national qui éclate toi tu arrives à
être la marionnette arrive sur l'écran
des guignols et dit merde mon fonds de
commerce qui se casse la gueule non que
je suis pas le seul à le dire je dirais
d'abord c'est une erreur parce que 10
casse pas la gueule j'ai deux font
commerce maintenant génial c'est que
maintenant qe2 front national il
faudrait ce qui est deux fois plus
d'étrangers pour en avoir autant tous
les deux bien non non juste là dessus ce
tout en prêtant c'est quand on tape sur
le front national dans le vrai journal
c'est toujours sur des sur des vrais
sujets nous dire on va chercher ils nous
disent on est un parti contre la
corruption on montre que c'est un parti
corrompu donc c'est là dessus c'est ça
consiste pas dire ah ils sont vilains
ils sont racistes etc c'est pas et tu
vois c'est plus important que c'est vrai
que c'est souvent argumenté d'alors
attend la vieille dans le cimetière
c'était terrible pour c'est clair vous
regardez le vrai journal de karl bien
sûr de oui oui surtout depuis que je
fais
morax éléments parfaitement sait
parfaitement bien car non tu m'as
découvert la radio en fait en venant à
l'europe c'est ça
oui c'était pas très facile parce
qu'effectivement c'est l'heure du
déjeuner en général chez moi on ne
regarde pas la télévision
on est jeune on est comme chez tes
parents non c'est pas sévère mais nous
avons autre chose à nous dire c'est un
moment de souffrance intérieure et vous
dépose sa plainte dénonce et si la vigne
de notre famille qui est assis on se
retrouve le dimanche et en étant content
de pouvoir parler entre nous voilà il
parle entre dernière question à dix
heures du soir tandis et de moquer d'un
dernière question les français s'avèrent
question tu as déclaré je refuse
d'interviewer des gens du fn c'est dans
ton émission le régional et jamais
personne du nom du fn non comme anne
sinclair c'est la même position
ouais je pense qu'il faut pas leur
donner la parole donc c'est normalement
vis-à-vis du csa j'ai pas le droit de
faire ça en période électorale je devrai
donner un temps de parole mais je ne
donne pas et puis j'attends la lettre du
csa gioria et puis voilà quoi ouais
jusqu'à présent ça parce que tu veux
c'est un accord un a passé avec alain de
greef et pierre lescure au début je leur
ai dit je prendrai personne du fn ils
ont dit ok c'est libre à toi quoi
avant de passer au débat on va regarder
un maigret me fait plus fort que le pen
parce que je maigrisse et l'open avec
deux yeux et il faut y penser avant de
rendre passer au débat et de recevoir
thierry pfister guy konopnicki et
laurent alliez on va regarder encore du
karl zéro un sketch qui est vraiment
marrant avec tous les ministres
socialistes qui fument un pétard on
regarde
maintenant que l'opposition toute
l'opposition depuis le bas jusqu'au est
particulièrement frileuses ce sujet nous
verrons bien
donc comment prouver à chemin mais on
connaît nos ambitions et si nous devions
les bornes et c'est tout simplement
parce que certains nous ont empêché de
le faire puisque vous savez il ya des
contraintes particulières au parlement
wallon du parlement pour faire passer
des projets sur ce sujet
labarthe et les prises dans les élus
problème c'est vrai et dans le secret
défense
elles sont mis l égérie sécurité dans
les quartiers populaires accompagné
d'une déontologie policière
l'abaissement mis dans les rapports des
français et même en suivant une ailière
l inter active et de l'opposition nous
rend il faut bien dire plutôt attrayante
il classe quoi dans la douce de la cité
et l'engagement
la mairie m'a pas déçu de rater voilà ce
qu'est voir réhabiliter pour nos
concitoyens
l'espace public
qui va
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
clo
[Musique]
voilà qu'un zéro la musique c'est george
harrison bon j appelle maintenant à
thierry feaster guy konopnicki et
laurent alliez thierry pfister bonsoir
dont vous êtes l'auteur d'un livre qui
s'appelle lettre ouverte aux gardiens du
mensonge chez albin michel où j'ai très
vite trois ans et pierre mauroy
mais en fait vous être onze ans chez
albin michel dont coréen parle toujours
de pierre mauroy en fait c'est surtout
alors pour vous ce que vous dites on va
en reparler après disponible dans votre
livre en fait si aujourd'hui pourquoi il
ya le politiquement correct pourquoi on
peut plus rien dire et tout c'est le
juridique c'est-à-dire comme aux états
unis
cette juridisme c'est vrai c'est en
attaque tout le monde donc on peut plus
rien dire quoi c'est le pen qui
attaquent charlie hebdo pour racisme
anti français
c'est d'une part une société de
connivences way qui fait que tout le
monde dont le meilleur exemple en
politique et la cohabitation
c'est à partir du moment où tout le
monde choisit de travailler ensemble de
s'échanger le pouvoir et qu'il n'y a
plus de responsabilités politiques que
même quand un président de la république
provoque des élections et les pères il
ne se sent pas obligé de me suggérer mr
elyria alors que jusqu'à destin par
exemple avait déjà expliqué que la vème
république au minimum en cas de
provocation d'élections pas le président
ici les périodes hivernales et donc tout
le monde
acceptant de ménage et tout le monde dès
qu une voix différente s'élève enfin
c'est difficile
en plus nous avons en france un système
juridique qui est l'un des plus
contraignants des démocraties
occidentales
il ya eu le cas avec delon récemment dû
de la vie privée mais nous sommes le
seul la seule démocratie occidentale qui
par exemple au nom d'une vieille
tradition française qui veut que tout le
monde soit ego ne fait pas de différence
entre les sommes publiques et le citoyen
de base ou entre les citoyens qui
utilisent une partie de leur vie privée
dans le débat public
ouais bon est ce que vous dites c'est
quasiment ou ségolène royal montre ses
enfants dans paris match
et bien après que c'était simplement un
homme politique qui fait comme il
l'avait fait jusqu'à par exemple des
affiches avec la femme et ses enfants
eh bien il est logique puisqu'il me
renvoie une image il me suggère une
image de sa vie personnelle et familiale
que je puisse enquêter pour vérifier
s'il est homosexuel ou pas je prends pas
les dons noticia casta vous avez été
vous
victime déjà il n'ya pas longtemps vous
êtes dans le coeur de métier vous avez
été victime de voies si vous vous a
attribué une liaison avec jean yves le
fur
moi j'étais désespéré parce que j'ai dit
cette fille quand elle est fraîche et
les formidables et joli tout ça et elle
est tombée vous jetez pas que ce n'est
pas vrai tu es tombé sur jean yves le
fur cela mais ça m'a flingué dans un
jour à hyogo si je crois que si juste
après vous avez démenti j'étais ravie
quand vous avez démenti parce que
j'étais tellement triste sérieusement je
trouve ça honteux
comment se décide pas mal et ses
oripeaux secondes quand justement je
crois ya un an de ça je sais que j'ai 19
ans et on dit que c'est mon premier
grand amour
oui et c'était le cinquième du nom mais
bien sûr en plus bon j'ai rien contre
lui mais comme il est avec toutes les
mannequine comme ça c'est la gigue enfin
c'est ça c'est trop facile mais c'est
pas c'est pas bien non je suis encore
s'asseoir ou s'allonger pas complètement
d'accord je suis sûr qu'avec tout ce
qu'ils ont ils dès 10h via une partie
que laquelle je sais que j'ai souscrit
partie à laquelle je souscris pas je
vous prends un exemple de giscard
d'estaing on va partir du moment où il
met sur une affiche électorale dont je
me souviens pas d'ailleurs sa femme et
ses enfants
on n'est pas forcément obligé d'aller
dans ces cabinets pour voir si fait caca
mou kaka dur je ne vois pas en quoi
si vous voulez
il ya quelque chose là dedans qui écrase
une formidable perversion des médias
aujourd'hui qui est clairement visée bon
moi je vais droit comme tout souffert de
voir si oui une fois bon très bien alors
je
non je veux dire par là qu'on n'est pas
au mieux on n'est pas obligé non si vous
utilisez votre vie familiale vos enfants
votre femme dans le débat public
à ce moment là oui vous êtes vous
procédez à un exemple quand on me voit
avec ma femme et enfant ou non
d'ailleurs peu importe dans ma maison
parce que je fais des trucs qu'on fait
reporter dans la maison on est forcément
obligé de penser que c'est le débat
public c'est pas le débat public le fait
que j'ai une maison que je souhaite ma
femme dans mon jardin en train de
regarder vers 10h20 intellectuelle vous
faites beaucoup de politiques par
exemple dans cette émission je fais pas
beaucoup de politiques j'exprime un
certain nombre d'opinions qui sont les
miennes sont obliger personne à en tenir
compte et avoir les mêmes c'est tout à
fait différent et d'ailleurs ça m'amuse
car disent ils conçoivent et les
amendements pouvait passer la provoc je
vais vous dire oui la provoc c'est pas
du tout quand ardisson porter des
lunettes noires et poser des questions à
la karl zéro la vraie provocation
la verve au rox et d'inviter pierre
arditi à une émission sur la provoc pour
s'entendre dire que sur la violence
urbaine la solution c'est quelque part
moyen entre répression et prévention ou
sur médecins que d'accord mais il faut
pas être trop ceci ou trop cela et faire
applaudir le public dans un panégyrique
du premier ministre ça c'est de la
provoc mais c'est la provoc au second
degré ne s'est pas la carte simplifiée
un peu quand même je vais je encore je
parlais de l'histoire médecin je vais
surtout allusion à la rumeur qui est une
chose que je fais je déteste et dont les
médias sont extrêmement friands en
particulier aujourd'hui en ce qui
concerne la présomption d'innocence
on voit des pages des pages entières
consacrées à des gens dont on ne sait
pas s'ils sont coupables ou non et si
par hasard ils ont le malheur de ne pas
l'être
il y aura un autre fils en dix septième
page du belge on a alors fait scandale à
la maison son innocence car arditi et
attendons la fin des procédures
c'est à dire que cinq ans après quand ça
sera passé en cassation on aura le droit
d'en parler tant qu'une rougeur on a
vidé d'outreau grandement les journaux
c'est vrai ça fin de la poule 1 les
allées de roland des 10% pas seulement
bien sûr roland dumas mais c'est pas le
seul il ya eu des tas d'autres choses
comme ça il ya eu dans dodo de leurs
griffes au palais de roland dumas dans
les journaux mais on peut en parler mais
il ya une manière d'en parler il ya deux
manières d'en parler il ya une manière
de gens parlent par exemple le journal
le monde que je lui en suis à fidèles
lecteurs qui n'est pas une manière qui
me convient personnellement parfaitement
bien il ya avait dépassé le
politiquement correct j'en ai trouvé une
trace il ya une manière de deux cas le
monde de parler de roland dumas qui fait
clair pour tout le monde
il est bien évidemment coupable moi
personnellement je lançais risque même
pas je ne sais pas s'il est coupable je
sais qu'il a dit tellement présente
comme la [ __ ] de la république a été
payée par un groupe industriel pour être
dans son lit c'est déjà un vrai problème
quant au fonctionnement des institutions
de la république c'est une vieille
histoire de
de l'humanité c'est une vieille histoire
de l'humanité tout à fait là bas mais
est ce que vous trouvez que c'est normal
à ce prix là c'est sûrement la presse
s'il appelle le pastis ou fêté ma place
ce sont des jeux là je ne fais que
saviez pas que j'étais juge ne devrait
pas faire ce qu'il fallait juste ne
doivent pas empiéter s'ils doivent
enquêter mais ne doit pas fax est le
résultat de leurs choses à la presse un
stade c'est peut-être ça qu on continue
à poursuivre leur enquête
oui sinon on arrête leur ok nous
d'accord alors on continue guy
konopnicki bonsoir vous êtes journaliste
l événement et vous publiez candide 2 le
retour chez flammarion
et alors que notre dernier invité à la
barre laurent alliez donc laurent alliez
vous êtes le frère de shanghai si je ne
disais pas ça se voit tout de suite
ah bon j'étais un peu mieux nourris que
lui quand même alors surtout quand je le
vois pas que j'entends la volage à toi
j'aurai des sorties du tournoi lors elle
passe par l'éducation sens on peut pas
parler de provocation son site et la
mémoire de notre ami jean edern hallier
vous avez déclaré ça c'est vraiment du
c'est pas tout le monde en parle pour le
coup et c'est vraiment personne n'en
parle
affaire s'est déclaré dans un journal
qui s'appelle généreux que jean edern
avait été assassiné j'ai la conviction
que ça arrange et beaucoup de gens qui
meurent et que très très facile de faire
mourir un cardiaque et que l'on m'a bon
jeter à l'eau bout de la france je suis
arrivé très vite mais quand même on n'y
a eu aucune enquête il ya eu aucune
espèce de on a fermé toutes les portes
on a il n'y a pas eu de topsy ya rien eu
c'est comme sur le tour de france
peut-être non c'est pas il était
cardiaque et il était seul depuis
trois heures ce que dit oui c'est un
vélo mais ce qu'a dit laurent alliez en
fait c'est qu'on a pu très bien mettre
quelques gouttes de heureux d'un produit
dans son café si l'un est qu'en faisant
du vélo mais laura car derrière comme
yves montand on va pas le déterrer c'est
mon sentiment je le dis les doutes sur
toutes les normes cessera irwin tous les
mois non mais il avait déjà été menacée
du temps de mitterrand
ouais il raconte ça dans bien sûr dans
l'honneur perdu et ses objets du commun
qui lui a filé 50000 bâton se tirer
c'est vrai qu'elle est menacée a été
réitéré l amont ou alors ça vous semble
plausible satya les festayres vous moi
ce qui m'a toujours surpris c'est qu'un
conseiller de l'elysée puisse mourir
dans son bureau à l'heure du journal
télévisé sans que personne en temps de
rien sans qu'on fasse de test et sans
qu'on retrouve aucun document ni rien
mais dans ce pays tout est possible le
risque est vrai c'est que la cellule
antiterroriste de l'elysée c'est-à-dire
la création d'une police illégale au
coeur de l'état français en violation de
toutes les règles administratives
pratiquant des écoutes clandestines a
été créés essentiellement d'abord pour
lutter contre monsieur jean edern
hallier
ce qui donne quelque chose par froid
dans le dos élevait revivre ce cas la
fois c'est dérisoire de dérisoire et en
même temps c'est terrifiant
ça vous énerve tout ce qu'on sort
maintenant sur l'époque mitterrand sur
le surtout le deuxième septennat faut
bien le dire d'ailleurs même si vous
hésitez pas fanatique du deuxième
syndicat et scanner non mais c'est pas
ça comme ça oui je vais pas l'entendre
parce que des foyers des jeunes
je remets mme les jambes non non mais je
ne remets ya une pédagogie de l'amnésie
maintenant il est évident des lic super
mais parce que le mec et j'ai deux
pièces en même temps il est la femme et
l'amant orléans
elle est jouée au théâtre du rond point
j'ai offert une réponse qui sera pas une
réponse politique s'il est simplement
une réponse humaine et c'est vrai que
j'ai un peu connu françois mitterrand un
peu pas beaucoup moins deux personnes
connaissaient dire alors disons que je
n'avais pas besoin de connaître d'autres
a besoin de le connaître moi c'était
simplement une relation humaine je
n'avais rien à demander je n'ai jamais
rien demandé à qui que ce soit
d'ailleurs
donc c'est quelqu'un qui m'a
effectivement fasciné très bien le jeu
je le dis moi même je lui ai toujours
dit j'étais moins clients du cette
deuxième septennat gelé d'ailleurs
largement ouvert cette époque là pour
bien faire comprendre je n'étais plus là
quoique un certain nombre de choses
il n'empêche que je ne trahis pas cette
cette émotion que j'ai eu connaissance
cet homme est que cette émotion je ne
l'a pas vrai pas quoi qu'on déterre
aujourd'hui on déterre avait consommé
theron déterrera aussi d'autres choses
je ne dis pas qu'il ne faut pas en
parler je ne suis pas pour qu'on le
culte les choses pas du tout je suis
pour qu'on ait des terres mais il ya
deux manières de les déterrer et elle
m'a l'air de faire la vérité qui nous
tiennent hommes et me faire la vérité
qui pue la merde diop liquide il faut
quand même dire que que jean edern lui a
parlé quand mitterrand était vivant et
au pouvoir et beaucoup de gens
aujourd'hui disent mon dieu c'était
affreux mitterrand mon dieu quelle
horreur étape mais enfin quand il était
vivant et au pouvoir on les entendait
pas où on entendait le bruit de leur
part qui faisait crisser les graviers
non là dans la cour de l'elysée
reconnaissons au point ça je n'en de
choses que jean edern disaient qu'ils
allaient ils exagèrent là il est fou là
il est parano l'aï déconne là et on
découvre un jour parce qu'il ya eu
enquête et qu'on ouvre un plat carré
copp route aux oublis des trucs dans un
garage dans les yvelines que c'était
vrai on appelait jean edern cheryl a
rappelé deux heures du matin d'hier
barracuda fin bon j'ai un truc à te
raconter je suis ratant deux heures du
matin non mais je suis écouté je peux
pas te raconter je suis écouté mais
c'était vrai je dis c'était vrai on va
revenir sur le débat la pro
boc aujourd'hui c'est quoi le
politiquement correct est partout qu'est
ce qu'il reste provoquant aujourd'hui
qu'est ce qui sépare vous à l'assemblée
nationale je vous dis vous avez fait
très très fort je crois que la
provocation aujourd'hui c'est de dire la
vérité et je trouve que c'est tout à
fait dommage sa vérité non non la
verrine rôle de la vérité et je pense
que le fait que l'on cache cette vérité
vous avez fait allusion à la
cohabitation pour moi la cohabitation
c'est véritablement le sommet du
mensonge et de l'ambiguïté et je crois
que ce cette construction
institutionnelle n'a fait que
qu'installer et une un politiquement
correct et qu' il faut absolument qu'il
y ait des voix qui se lève et qu'elle
ait le courage de dire si elles sont
contradictoires et surtout si elles sont
contradictoires
bien je crois que l'idée c'est toujours
de ce cui les idées reçues du moment et
pour moi les idées reçues durant celle
ci l'avait reçue c'est aussi de penser
que canal+ et la chaîne de la liberté
parce que je vous rend attentifs à un
détail quand je le premier quotidien
français a été créé c'est sur dérogation
accordée par louis xiii à son secrétaire
particulier théophraste renaudot
c'est-à-dire son directeur de cabinet et
quand canal+ a été créé c'est par une
dérogation finances initiale pour le
directeur de cabinet de françois
mitterrand n'y a pas eu de changements
en quatre siècles une question par
exemple si je dit mme boutin quand on a
pleuré je m'en foutais parce qu'il
fallait bien qu elle mouil de quelque
part ça c'est de la provocation non
c'est de la recherche
alors oui alors la provocation la vraie
provocation serait maintenant le talent
tout simplement parce qu'il n'ya aucune
révélation dans les livres de jean edern
sinon la façon dont il l'a dit et tout
le monde le savait en 83 de l'honneur
perdu de françois mitterrand et le
cancer elle a collaboré mazarine et tout
ça et personne ne l'a répété donc il y
avait un consensus de 2 mais si le
talent il a mis dix ans à le publier et
il se consoler en disant que victor hugo
avait mis 19 ans pour publier les
châtiments
ok le décès de jean edern est une
provocation en soi oui c'est quand même
le seul à nier qu'ils soient morts sur
une plage du département 50 ans après
rien c'est drôle
alors avant de madame du cas je vous dis
au revoir au revoir à tous avant de se
quitter on va regarder un truc qui est
pas mal aussi ça vient malheureusement
de l'étranger je pense pas que ça passe
sur canal quand même ça ça s'appelle
absolutely fabulous
[Musique]
c'est gestion des congés pas moi
c
marché des salles wire
alors on va passer au troisième débat de
la soirée les anges existe film est
d'abord on va faire pierre arditi une
hyper view bah oui bah oui c'est vrai
que ça vous tombe dessus un moment là
avec chez moi à faire une hyper view qui
sera donnée vous donner en plus
l'occasion de répondre à un certain
nombre de papiers que j'ai vu sur vous
dernièrement et qui étaient pas tous
très sympathiques en tous les cas
donc on va vous pouvez poser des
questions aussi à pierre arditi petit
pas sur les mêmes que moi mais sur des
sujets plus progressive location plus
intéressante qu'elle est plus
intéressante que moi ça sera difficile
alors il y avait un article dans libé
c'était lundi dernier loris 11 qui
disait pierre arditi talent caché caché
chu teh il parlait de vous en disant
vous faites partie des acteurs qui
pompent les gros le gros des cachets de
la fiction à la télé et il parlait de
stars vieillissantes
oui bon parce que comme on a presque le
même âge je trouve ça ignoble je tiens à
le dire
d'abord forêts faudra expliquer à la
personne qui a écrit ça dont je ne sais
pas de nom puisque c'est maintenant
c'est juste des initiatives et que
paris-nice ya plus tard c'est exagéré
vous dois moment là parce que c'est très
exactement ce que valait 10 livres la
sega vous d'abord faudrait déjà cessé
d'employer ce mot à tord et à travers
pas ce qui ne signifie plus rien une
star c'est quelque chose de très
particulier il y en a extrêmement peu je
n'en fais pas partie
alors c'est pas du tout de la fausse
modestie chez moi je ne suis absolument
pas une star ensuite bon je ne vois pas
trop l'intérêt de
de me regarder de cette manière là
d'abord bien évidemment je ne pompe pas
à moi tout seul l'ensemble de l'argent
de la fiction on voit que sur certains
certaines chaînes ils en font tellement
peu qu'après tout on peut penser que
jean propre une bonne partie cette
sortie de pas citer de noms voilà non
mais je veux dire par là que je n'ai
rien à dire sur le fait qu'on puisse
critiquer en l'occurrence une série de
télévision qui s'appellerait un font six
que j'ai tourné que brigitte fossey
vanek du prr un certain nombre d'autres
je comprends très bien qu'on n'aime pas
ça on a tout à fait le droit de dire ça
me choque absolument pas je n'ai rien à
dire là dessus je ne vois pas l'intérêt
de me et de taper la gueule de cette
manière là d'abord parce que tout ça est
évidemment totalement faux je ne
fonctionne pas plus qu'un certain nombre
d'autres gens qui travaillent dans la
finance et même chaîne ensuite mon dieu
je suis j'ai toujours dit je crois que
je monte sur un acteur
pluridisciplinaire ça que je fais du
théâtre du cinéma de la télévision
quelquefois même jeudi les textes que je
mon honneur à moi c'est de passer d'un
rennais a fait 2 ou de beckett à guitry
que je considère que mon métier c'est ça
que j'ai été baigné dans ce bain là
puisque nous avons à peu près le même
âge et que nous avons été biberonné à
rob est riche que c'est ma vie brawn est
robert hirsch
j'ai été biberonné à jouer j'ai été
biberonné à brasseur je ne me compare
pas à eux mais autant que je m'en
souvienne ces gens là faisait aussi un
peu ça c'est à dire que brasseur disait
lui-même
je vais m'amuser dans la journée je vais
faire mon métier le serrures tout bon
donc je vois pas en quoi cette chose
sera une tare ensuite que soit
vieillissant naturellement je suis
vieillissant je trouve que finalement je
finis plutôt pas trop mal montré plutôt
mieux avec bercy 7 5
est ce que est ce que vous pensez que
pierre arditi vit bien franchement oui
je trouve qu'un homme un homme est plus
beau quand tu as passé dix ans mais les
filles sont les femmes mais beaucoup
plus beaucoup continuer parce qu'il
devient plus mature et voilà c'est vrai
je sais pas on ne sait pas mais voilà
tout ça tout ça simplement pour dire
tout ça pour dire eh bien cette grotte
non tout ça tout ça pour dire que ça m'a
profondément déplu non pas qu'on n'aime
pas cette série sagement colvin tape
complètement mais que cette manière de
me regarder
je la trouve infâme et finalement comme
dirait l'autre il ya des lettres qui
vaut mieux recevoir plutôt de les avoir
écrites pas de déshonneur leurs auteurs
ces six minutes ça vous emmerde rémois
oui je relèverai bien sûr vous avez
raison ça me ça me blesse parce qu'une
certaine manière c'est un journal que
j'aime bien et c'est un journal que je
lis pratiquement tous les jours mais ma
lecture de libération s'arrête aux pages
politiques d'économie que je ne lis plus
les pages culturelles de libération qui
sont j'ai le regret de le dire
des pages totalement incomplète pour le
moins qui en ce sens une toute petite
partie de ce qui se passe culturellement
dans notre pays et en conséquence de
quoi je trouve que les pages culturelles
de libération ne font pas leur boulot
non pas parce qu'elle ne m'attaque mois
mais encore une fois ça me blesse
puisque j'aime bien ce journal je veux
dire que cette manière de regarder fait
un peu penser à une presse d'occupation
qui tout d'un coup deviendrait racisme
alors je n'ai pas envie qu'on devienne
racistes avec moi je crois n'avoir rien
fait dans ma vie qui mérite ce
traitement la très bien non mais ce
qu'on pourrait se dire est ce que le
fait d vous avez cinq ans de 3 ans donc
est ce que le ceat 54 est-ce que je suis
jeune que vous alors est-ce que le
dernière question avant de passer à
rêver peut-être vous préparé une série
pour france 2 qui s'appelle les 80 unarc
et donc qu'ils parlent des gens de
gauche qui ont perdu leur âme après 80
parle d'une de tout de tout un groupe de
gens qui traversent cette période au
moment où la gauche arrive au pouvoir
qu'ils sont pas forcément de gauche
je n'ai pas ce sentiment a perdu votre
âme vous non je n'ai pas l'impression
d'avoir perdu mon âme et je n'ai pas
l'impression que tous les gens de gauche
est forcément perdu leur âme même si à
certains moments ils se sont un peu
perdus
très bien alors on en arrive à rêver
peut-être donc et la pièce qu de jean
claude grumberg que vous jouez au
théâtre du rond point des champs elysées
avec michel aumont marcel maréchal et
chantal neuwirth mise en scène de jean
michel ribes or ce que je veux dire
parce que là je suis pas critique de
cinéma eric est donc là au québec de
théâtre etc et non plus vrai c'est vrai
qu'on est allé voir cette pièce est que
les dieux main dans la main dans la main
puisque maintenant comme vous le savez
un ensemble on attaque cédant que non
mais sérieusement on sait je veux dire
c'est une pièce grave
mais le texte est tellement drôlement
écrit avec certaines fois d'ailleurs
grunberg le deed un côté un peu al mana
vermont et c'est tellement mis en scène
une façon joyeuse par ribes que
finalement un thème aussi grave
quelqu'un qui veut venger son père dans
le père a disparu pendant la guerre qui
veulent venger enfin j'en parle mal
parce que dit nous c'est un rêve en fait
ce qui est formidable c'est que c'est
comme ça c'est comme un rêve comme un
rêve
oui mais c'est au fond la pièce elles
disent que ce que grumberg a assez
souvent dit il est obsédé par l'image de
ce père déporté qu'il ne connaît pas et
au fond à l'intérieur de ce dans
l'atelier le levain thématique est très
classique avait très terrienne on attend
quelqu'un doit revenir là revenir ici on
voit apparaître une sorte de spectre qui
est un spectacle qui est à la fois le
spectre d'annette mais qui est aussi le
spectre de ce père perdu simplement les
dans le domaine du rêve et on est dans
le domaine de la nuit et là le combat de
la nuit l'a emporté sur le combat du
jour et la nuit
tout est possible tout est permis mais
plus rien ne sera un penny oui c'est ça
en fait la thématique de la pièce ça me
au milieu d'un magma qu'est celui d'un
rêve globale qui comme dans tous les
rêves semblent n'avoir ni queue ni tête
et quand même petit tableau qui bien
entendu ça prend une cohérence et bien
on ira par par emmené par en skis comme
est en réalité d'ailleurs cet enfant
homme vers sa douleur initial qui est
celle de la perte de ce pays un enfant
atteint son but par chantal neuwirth au
début c'est ça c'est son épouse après
c'est sa mère dans sa femme c'est vrai
on dirait je sais pas si c'est une bonne
façon d'envoyer les gens dans la pièce
mais ça fait penser à un bon trip
d'acide quoi c'est bien bien dribbler
150g tous les baby boomer comprendront
ce que je veux dire
très bien merci pierre bon alors
prochains débats les
ange existe-t-il alors pour en parler
avec nous jean charles de castelbajac
vous y croyez on va en parler monsieur à
douzy croix de troupes selon me croyez
vous êtes un spécialiste du sujet
monsieur blanc lui voue moyen-moyen mes
coups ça couci couça et bercoff alors
lui n'en parlons pas lui c'est le libre
penseur rationaliste que tout ça fait
hautement rigoler alors jean charles de
castelbajac
alors vous dites intel croit me dit j'ai
jamais cru au père noël mais j'ai
toujours cru aux anges c'est vrai c'est
vrai c'est un peu pour ça vous êtes là
vous dira alors racontez nous cette
anecdote parce qu'un jour est dans un
aéroport et et vous faites arrêter je
faisais pas de régime gt gt en transit
entre entre le rio et tokyo en passant
par new york et je n'ai pas dit ça et de
fait je suis rentré et escorté par deux
policiers dans un dieu qui est un lieu
où j'allais m'en allais me rafraîchit et
je vois un monsieur témoins dadir les
toilettes
oui mais chacun sa typologie
d'expression chacun fait comme il veut
réussir une étoile a dit si on dirait
qu'ils n'ont absolument pas dessinée
mettant dit la vérité et je vois je vois
ce jeune homme qui est en train de
travailler sur une boîte en carton et
des regardent à l'intérieur et j'ai eu
ce que certains appellera une intuition
d'autres un pain pressentiment j'ai eu
comme une voie que m'a murmuré de partir
donc je suis parti j'ai fait lé 10
mètres et et les toilettes ont explosé
attentats attentats par il était sauvé
son nom j'avais confiance et croire à
ces extraordinaires parce que s'ils
voulaient les concours de circonstances
ce fragment d'espace-temps vous vous
retrouvez en transit dans un lieu dans
un aéroport y ait jamais eu dans une vie
lui l'attentât et de se trouver avec un
terroriste portoricain qui fait exploser
les toilettes de la report de kennedy
j'ai jamais une couverture médiatique
aussi forte puisque j'ai été interviewé
par cette chaîne de télévision sur le
parking de khalidié recorde c'était à ce
moment là au moment de l'interview vous
leur avez dit oui c'est mon ange gardien
qui m'a prévenu
pas tout à fait parce que moment
l'interview j'étais je pouvais être
soupçonnée j'étais la dernière personne
qui avait été
ah oui dans le lieu ah oui alors vous ne
cessez un postérieur et moi je crois que
j'en ai pris conscience dans le vol qui
m'enerve décider des anges sur les murs
là c'est devenu à paris il dessinait
souvent des engins c'est assez joli dans
les dans ces endroits où il ya des
plaques qui commémore absolue des gens
qui sont morts la libération et des
jeunes gens je pense l'agent de bretagne
et et vous et vous dessinez des vous
vous d'essayer des anges en douteraient
fait dit rekom c'est d'être un guide ses
pas et s'est dit très à la cresse et
pour certains c'est alors ça a été
assimilée à des tags et ou alors sonné
absolue c'est juste ces gens par gestes
ce qui est assez étonnant c'est que je
ne signe pas bien sûr mais je mets la
date et que je repasse parfois deux ans
après ouais et qui sont toujours là
alors je leur ouvre les yeux parce
qu'aujourd'hui c'est souvent pour les
tchèques ont dit rien on va compter les
tissages et pas plus parce que je peux
aussi leur ouvrir les yeux
j'ignorais je vous sens trompé signal
oran pour laetitia lé non je ne signe
pas avant mais pour les pour pourquoi
pour laetitia mais voilà alors que
souvent je repasse un an après ouais et
je fais à vouloir ouvrir les yeux prenez
le temps de réfléchir
on est de 15 voilà ce qu'il faut dire
d'ailleurs ce qui est encore plus
magique c'est que la cré de cela crée ne
sait pas vraiment ce qui est assez
étonnant c'est qu'on voit à l'asco par
exemple qui peut en charbon c'est la
pérennité et les robes qu'on voit
derrière vous sont des sondés alors je
serais très touché que vous vous leviez
parce que maintenant vous en venez c'est
joli à ces jeux oui c'est très charmant
oui c'est très charmant il ya toujours
castelbajac en haut ça en haut sous le
col écrit castelbajac
c'est un souvenir de l'école ses
pensionnaires absolument c'est ça c'est
vraiment les réécrit cas c'est la même
éthique est très sympa alors on va y
revenir monsieur asian vous écrivent dix
ouvrages sur les anges
est ce que vous arrivez à savoir si les
gens vous avez en face de vous on des
anges gardiens oui très bien alors paul
éric blanrue vous vous alors vous ne
croyez pas du tout vous tous à vous êtes
vous lutter contre ce genre de choses
vous avez écrit un bouquin qui contre le
fera contre compte la véracité du saint
suaire de turin qui s'appelle miracle ou
imposture qui est paru chez golias
d'ailleurs qui est une librairie
catholique de lyon et andré bercoff donc
bof c'est pas spécialement sensible aux
anges ou séries que je crois pas je
crois pas qu'il ya des petits oiseaux
volent temps au tour et qui nous disent
qu'il faut faire et quant à la voie
alors là c'est très intéressant parce
que tout problème c'est un bouquin sur
jeanne d'arc et dont rémy ouais et en
fait on a su que jeanne d'arc n'avais
jamais entendu des voix dans la nuit
alors été sourde et muette béziers
la voix c'est aussi intérieur je crois
que je fais et donc je vois pas ce qu'on
antique jeanne d'arc c'était un ange son
ange qui lui parlait c'est ça non jeanne
d'arc c'était défense était allé c'était
le stade supérieur
l'archange saint michel aussi je vais
l'accrocher soeur sandrine et sainte
marguerite
mais bon je crois que si chacun besoin
de ça c'est bien si on en a besoin
cela dit vous êtes cas christine boutin
avec les homosexuels faisaient de la
compassion pour les gens qui croient aux
anges pour un bout de la compassion
alors voilà la compassion est quelque
chose que je déteste
alors quelqu'un qui se penche sur la
position de christine boutin mais n'est
pas là ça m'embête
ouais ça la position non c'est la
position de la tireuse coucher sa main
est je crois qu'on n'a pas avoir de
compassion parce que ça fait
condescendant c'est ce que je vais dire
on regarde les gens là et on leur dit
j'ai de la compassion pour vous dire
quoi ce moment ça veut dire que si jean
charles de castelbajac se sent bien avec
ses anges
bravo pour lui parce qu'il faut quand
même bien voir qu'aujourd'hui il ya de
nombreux insectes qui se créent enfants
dont le phénomène sectaire ex du jeu
boisseau alors il ya de nombreux gourou
qui se prétend directement inspirées par
des anges et qui fonde une petite secte
qui va grandir grossir etc et qui vont
donc exploiter la crédulité humaine
alors ça effectivement c'est beaucoup
plus dangereux notionnels effectivement
contre ça je suis contre la alors là
l'artiste a tous les droits qu'ils
n'avaient pas effectivement référence
aux anges et c'est très bien il avait
absolument tous les droits donc c'est
beau l'artiste peut faire ce qu'il veut
pas trop de commerces avec quoi quand on
voit sur un panneau vidange gratuite
faut pas y croire vous vous sentez vous
sentez attaquer quand on dit ça qu'un
vrai c'est vrai moi là pour préparer
l'émission je pense j'ai dû recevoir 15
livres sur les hanches quoi c'est c'est
beaucoup mais moi je crois que c'est
plus qu'une mode j'aurai je crois que
c'est
c'est une c'est en phase avec le début
du siècle prochain
située à paris j'ai vraiment le
sentiment que on a vu quand même
au niveau commercial comme vous le
disiez aussi la mode des démons des
diablotins qui vendait des camemberts
enfin elle a vu des affiches dans tout
paris où les nico vendus par satan et
tout je trouve ça éminemment plus
sympathique de voir un parfum vendu par
un ange dans le métro une photo de
mondino
ouais je trouve que ça appelle à quelque
chose de plus paisible très bien
laetitia vous vous y croyez aux en jour
quand vous écoutez de la musique vous
écouter mozart sur un rocher en corse au
bord de la mer ce qu'on vit des anges je
crois surtout à l'instinct et vous
thierry vous dit quoi votre ange gardien
dans votre oreillette d'un moment je
gardais à me dit que dès le départ et
hier une très jolie phrase de roger
martin gardant les thibault qui dit il
avait renoncé à appeler dieu tout ce
qu'il ne comprenait pas voilà alors on
pourrait éventuellement crois pas non
plus oui c'est pas une affaire de
croyance
ses pensées c'est affaire de logique
ça n'a rien à voir il faut vous que vous
le kipling disait rêve mais ne laisse
pas le rêve devenir tomber vous servir
les rave parties
je dirais pour finir comment avais mon
journal que j'ai le sentiment que autour
de cette table dans cette salle et où un
certain moment on va appeler son ange
alors asie elle va vous dire son âge je
connais l'ange donc jean coutton rester
en contact plus tôt possible a dit l eau
vivres oui je connais ça s'agissant ces
sonneries s'appelle comment devient 24
février xavier louy ce 24 février à
24,24 je connais ma date de naissance
il s'appelle il me revient certainement
jouit dans l'eau c'était déjà dans à
volonté dans la série je me disais dire
c'est quoi c'est la logique de
croissance est très jolie s'est pas non
plus mais ça je suis pas au courant
mesdames messieurs je vois mon ange
gardien me dit effectivement que c'est
terminé je vais vous remercier tout vous
pouvez rester en dhr et parce qu'un truc
un trait qui s'appelle box office
auxquelles j'aimerais que vous
participiez salut à tous merci d'être
venus bonne année connaît pas pierre je
vous laisse je vous laisse filer parce
que avec la vie que vous avez eu les
bébés restent dans l'élan ch oui oui
avec la vie que vous avez en ce moment à
une heure et demie sur scène le soir
la maintenance est compté pour moi oui
j'ai effectué beaucoup de temps vous
savez je suis à la fin fin fin des
choses avec ses 53 ans égale et
récoltent 4 50 54
les trois femmes de sa compagne depuis
salsa foule quand une allure phénomène
merci merci à bergholtz blanrue adyel
castelbajac et avoue pierre d'avoir été
notre compagnie a au docteur cloud
quand même des prêts mars y ai parlé à
nos anges alors mesdames messieurs quand
on juge les a fait pas il ya maintenant
la dernière séquence de l'émission qui
s'appelle box office mais boxe avec un
peu donc on va prendre des sauvages des
hit parades des classements qui
paraissent chaque semaine dans la presse
et on va essayer de voir si c'est pas si
c'est vrai dans tous les cas si on est
d'accord avec eux alors on va prendre
les hommes les plus sexys qu'est paru
dans gala à la fin de l'année les
glandes or qui est paru dans vsd à la
même époque
et puis ensuite on faire quand même
notre classement à nous ça s'appelle les
gens les plus énervants voilà alors on
commence avec les hommes les plus sexys
paru dans dans gala alors pour gala les
hommes les plus sexys son job cluny
musée cluny
pas sexy du tout parce qu'il a été cloné
voir comment il m'a allumé lacoste j'ai
toute une chance moi chérie tu a aucun
souci à ce faire j'ai aucune chance avec
lm arditi plus pourtant ces macabres
avoir gelé soutenu georges clooney
connais les mecs d'urgence le maître du
rjr âge voilà mon côté c'est que si vous
moi je m'en fiche nos femmes et les
filles derrière qui disent ici la
nécessité
didier carreiras me connaissent et
olivier qui sait qui c'est qui sait
regarder je suis pas d'accord je vais
droit à un joker c'est un garçon qui
anime une émission qui s'appelle
pourquoi ça marche sur m6 est-ce que ça
m'a bien non pas pourquoi ça marche une
autre whisky de la pelouse une façon il
fait gendry des risques de remise en
fait mr bean eastern sakineh sexy mr
blizzard est alors ça me ferait ça
m'effraie beaucoup chine
il est bien ça me ferait non si c'est
très bien c'est pas votre génération
bien sûr c'est la connaît
l'extraordinaire je me souviens de perec
way à bicyclette au théâtre dansé arts
et yves montand et romy schneider et
femme et l'amant de rami schneider et ce
fut l'amant brigitte bardot pendant
longtemps alors tourner les pages
patricia montrer montraient des gens
dont on parle alors ça me ferait antonio
banderas il est passé non ça c'est
d'envié vous deviendra
non non non non c'est pas un énorme bond
spécialiste en boues l'acteur john
patricia antonio banderas
oui oui et encore oui mais je n'ai pas
tout lu au sergent garcia
bien sûr ils vont finir l'émission l'a
alors après tout de suite il est là paul
auster wiki c'est paul auster way s'est
s'impliqué bien julien clerc julien car
vous connaissez j'aime beaucoup julien
clerc il plairait julien clerc
franchement oui
non non non mais c'est bien sur la meme
reconnaît présente je vais rester le
seul qui est vieillissant tout ça mais
par rapport aux autres lui il a pas de
cheveux gris savez tout est là mais vos
cheveux bien pu dire non bill clinton
pas du tout sexy bill clinton sexuelle
peut-être celle ci touche pas à mon
cochon et touchante
rigole défendre le bill clinton temps
c'est impossible qui lui arrive
oui pour une fellation furtivité
l'assiette comme tous les français
avaient compris ce qu'on lui reprochait
c'était un parcours est pas une
fellation alors kiki qui m'ont qui dit
la vérité entrevoyez vous dire oui
alors ça n'existe pas l'incroyable hulk
à mon âge avancé à harceler paula jones
a pris le fil 1 million de dollars pour
qu'elle se taise voilà rassurés c'est à
dire s'il veut la donner du liquide pour
qu'elle ferme la bouche
[Applaudissements]
pierre des gros où es tu ensuite un avis
publié hier des gros première à paula
jones était quand même le premier
taille-crayon faudra payer il ya eu
après monica way monica lewinsky elles
sont plusieurs quand même ça non mais je
trouve qu'il est formidable c'est un
signe de bonne santé ce qui est un peu
plus inquiétant c'est qu'on ait
finalement le monde est gouverné
bizarrement ça c'est sûr ces supporters
de foot à l'elysée un obsédé aux états
unis et un ivrogne en russie donc ça
c'est inquiétant mais les obsédés sont
plus rassurants que les autres vous
savez oui parce qu'il pense pas ça la
guerre pendant ce temps là ah ouais ben
ali si vous étiez déjà oublié c'est la
honte on empêche de tirer son coup il ya
d'autres coûts ouais ça alors les
manuels petit toujours je parle du
sondage gahler a football assez sexy
sexy ça oh non je passais que si pour
laetitia vous pouvez nous départager là
mais non mais non à mon goût oui non
football à la retraite je servais là moi
non
bon alors le meilleur 5 c'est dommage
parce qu'il vient de quitter sa femme
oui oui je m'en parle oui c'est triste
et c'est arrivé jean valsaque
normalement les gens chez nous alors et
felipe gomes felipe colleau
il est beau mais c'est dans leurs 10 ans
pas du tout ben ouais je luis felipe
d'espagne et comme un imbécile qui tombe
la neige alors que c'est le fils du roi
d'espagne vous trouver sexy vous suisse
des rois d'espagne mais pas au niveau
il ya de très beaux yeux mais les pas de
très sexy bats toi qui sais du tout si
c'est le prochain roi d'espagne comme
stéphane bern dans ces conditions là
justement ronan chéneau laurent passe au
gland d'or de vsd alors le blanc le
gland d'or a été disputée à auckland au
gland d'or basset clinton qui doit être
le gland d'or a été décernée à stéphane
bern justement non en télé oui tu vois
pourquoi je sais pas moi non plus c'est
vrai que c'est vrai que c'est vrai que
ben on l'a vu beaucoup il est un peu
comme tout ce qu'on voit beaucoup ça à
gaza mardi oui mais par du nom mais ils
lèchent bien lui arriver très bientôt
ouais c'est le gland d'or a été démis de
lèche majesté prendre ou à laisser
alors ppda gland d'argent et guillaume
durand go blanc de bronze
pourquoi guillaume durand mais je sais
pas c'est vsd mois tous les ans un mois
je vais lire après qu'il est nerveux
très curieux et environs s'est très vite
parce que voilà donc ces vsd alors dans
le sport là il n'ya que des gens donc
qu'on attend complètement
il ya virenque ah oui via douillet david
douillet le jeune musée et à les y
pousse à aller et en politique alors la
suite désolé pour vous que les steen le
gland d'or vous christine boutin bien
sûr que j'aurais comparé à clécy bravo
qui fait l'émission samedi prochain à
temps du récit notre ami fait l'émission
samedi prochain et donc danser christine
boutin qui est glandeurs en politique
oui ça paraît tout à fait justifiée
justifié wemmel vous la connaissez vous
trouvez aussi qu'elle mérite le ballon
d'or
[Musique]
je m'appelle
il arrivera mais rideau de la touche et
s'en était venu chez vous c'est adriana
karembeu ou jaurès et laetitia casta
j'aurai à faire devenir un terreau il ya
des belles gonzesses ici elle était
belle gose haine des espoirs sont permis
alors le pen invitée partout et par tous
il est même gland d'or en deux après
boutin et tibéri notre matin tard on
devrait diviser le gardeur de l'open
avec maigri un de mes joueurs dans le
cinéma
le gland d'or de vsd a été attribué à
claude lelouch ensuite alain delon et
alors là je trouve qu'on va caprio je
vois pas pourquoi caprio un leonardo oui
les nanobots j'ai bien au fond de toi il
vous plait est-ce que vous enviez
virginie ledoyen qui va tourner avec
leonardo dicaprio
non mais franchement bon je trouve que
leonardo et dormait renardeau je vais
bien qu'arthur non non excusez moi
j'étais parfait dans le rôle de julia
c'est très bien non mais moi j'aime
beaucoup leonardo n'a rien contre moi je
me mets bien
george clooney est en fait libanaise en
chanson en chanson tu crois que je suis
en chanson les tout est à la maison
non non non non non non non non on
n'aime pas les [ __ ] les toubitri ntm ce
même thème
je partage l'avis de vsd parce que c'est
vraiment des glands et obispo
voilà tu es obispo la whey alors après
les gens qui nous énerve alors qui vous
énerve maintenant ça j'ai juste fait un
classement à nous la la on arrête de
parler de vsd nul on pense nounou keane
qui vous énerve le plus laurent ruquier
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui dans la semaine
je dirais qu'à chevènement autant
évidemment quand il était dans le coma
on hier voilà il ya une certaine
compassion et reviens parce que c'était
normal parce qu'il était sur son lit
d'hôpital
même si c'était pas le premier ministre
l'intérieur dans le coma qu'on avait eu
parce qu'on avait lui devrait juste
avant 0 mais mais mais franchement là ça
commence à bien faire ce coup c'est le
sol
le miraculé a l'impression veillé par du
lot de belfort qui va être mise en vente
bientôt pour asperger les voici
qu'aujourd'hui jean pierre chevènement
est en corse tout le monde est comme ça
c'est une apparition et bien géré on le
touche le jeu avec la gc chez les noms
et les rhénans cité dans cette loi mais
je voudrais dire quelque chose moi
j'étais persuadé que les médecins
avaient opéré sur le cerveau je ré
persuadé qu'on allait leur trouver un
des neurones autrement a placé autrement
pas du tout la commande anarchy saison
[Musique]
c'est le professeur debré qui est un
grand chirurgien qui vérifie les
cerveaux de son frère
bon alors vous ce qui vous savez vous
patricia qui bouge qui vous a le plus
énervé moi je vais revenir par l'état
leur moi c'est plutôt les voyants
partout sans arrêt avec leur
traditionnel prévisions du mois de
janvier et j'en ai trouvé un alors
particulièrement gratiné aux etats unis
c'est une d'ailleurs elle s'appelle
mystique mag
et alors elle nous annonce on en revient
jamais j'y reviens mais elle nous
annonce que ben jelloun il va arrêter le
cinéma et qui va monter un élevage de
porcs
ouais donc sa mission sur la mer ça
marche pas du studio ouais j'ai eu dix
jours dont vous c'est cette joyeuse
janvier cinq minutes jordi aussi quand
même le retour de jordi cette semaine on
a vu sur ton ordi ça c'est quand même
extraordinaire de gamme à 11 ans les
parents le ressorte des fait son come
back en un sens ce qui est drôle c'est
que il dit maintenant il fait de la
techno pour faire jaune serait alors moi
je dois je peux dire qui m'a énervé il
ya jane birkin je suis désolé jane
ça fait 30 ans que tu es en france et
franchement dire toujours le porte le
maison le tabouret honnêtement
franchement on n'y croit plus là bas
alors pas france est normalement et tout
ira bien niger unis comme toujours dit
justin et comme tout le monde
en tous les cas comme vous aimez
sûrement autant que moi jane birkin vous
irez l'avoir tant au pardon tu dormais
au théâtre de la gaîté mars malgré tout
ce qu'on peut penser si on les planches
on la voit quand même mais sur les
planches ça va voilà elle joue dans la
théâtre vous savez ça voilà d'autres
gens qui vous ont énervé
dommage que pour venir justement avec
quelqu'un que j'admirais gratte qu'elle
a nous admirer un porno craft spells
larry flynt ou équivalent j'étais
millions $ en disant qu'ils vont
dénoncer mais je trouve formidable alors
j'ai reçu et cette fois la semaine
prochaine pour en parler ouais thierry
c'est le rapport flint ouais il vaut
largement le rapport star raconte toutes
les histoires des types défenseur des
valeurs familiales et même les pires des
pires hypocrite mais c'est pareil c'est
toujours par être qui vous énerve ou un
par mois
en fait parfois quand je marche dans la
rue je vois les femmes avec leurs
enfants quand il fait froid et ça c'est
celle de m'énerver
pourquoi est ce que voulait absolument
faire des enfants non c'est un envoi
mais je comprends pas qu'on puisse se
servir un enfant pour gagner de l'argent
comme ça c'est souvent alors 17 ans
encore faire des vous êtes politiquement
quand ça vous énerve fabrication qu'on
utilise 200 fin de compte c'est ce que
font les parents aujourd'hui dans
libération
dans les versions de libération d'hier
on nous raconte comme le couple
l'histoire d'un couple russe oui à
courchevel a laissé son son enfance
d'une poussette a fallu en général dans
la station de ski tout le monde se
passait j'étais un enfant abandonné et
est en fait il faisait moins 7 degrés à
-7° à courchevel du monde pensait que ce
sens cet enfant allait mourir et les
parents russes sont sortis d'un
restaurant qui était quelques mètres
plus loin désormais occupez vous de ce
qui vous regarde chez nous il fait
beaucoup plus froid que ça et on est
dehors sans problème voilà très bien je
veux quelqu'un qui veuille vraiment même
site
pour patrick timsit parce qu'il n'a pas
osé aller jusqu'au bout alors je trouve
que patrick timsit qui commence à la si
on peut plus parler
les personnes alors lui commence à
parler et puis il s'excuse il faut une
fondation avec la famille etc
je veux dire
il jouait il faut dire les gens qu'un
patrick timsit a dit dans un sketch les
mongoliens c'est comme les crevettes
roses à part la tête tout est bon voilà
alors bon on peut on peut contester ou
pas mais le problème et c'est qu'à ce
moment là alors si on parle on fait des
blagues juives les blagues arabes les
blancs c'est politiquement ça veut dire
qu'on ne peut plus rien dire de quoi que
ce soit parce qu'à ce moment là vous
aurez là qu'en 2006 où ces taxes va dire
commencer le politique c'est que chacun
veut faire valider ses propres valeurs
par un tribunal
c'est le politiquement correct c'est le
pen qui attaquent charlie hebdo pour
racisme anti français
c'est ça le politiquement correct oui
j'ai alors si vous en voulez un qui
m'énerve et qui a un rapport avec ce
qu'on vient de dire c'est jean tiberi
puisque j'ai appris cette semaine que
j'ai été mis en examen sur ordre de jean
tiberi pour avoir dit sur une antenne
sur france2 d'ailleurs chez michel
drucker que sur les champs elysées quand
le tour de france est arrivé l'été
dernier y avait pas grand monde pour
accueillir les coureurs un chirac et
jospin ne se battait pas contrairement
au mondial que c'est tout juste ses
pages jacques balutin qui leur a remis
le trophée au pouvoir et que finalement
c'était jean tiberi qui était à
l'arrivée et que c'était un super choix
formidable le choix d'avoir pris jean
tiberi pour accueillir les coureurs
parce qu'à côté de lui les coureurs
avaient l'air honnête on vous attaque
pour ça même pas bien méchant
franchement non là mais ces procès pour
ça mais c'est fou d'attaquer nos
mémoires à table tout le monde des
humoristes des satiristes où on les
laisse dire ce qu'ils veulent
oui donc s'y prendre je serai prêt avec
les parents de jean tiberi a créé voilà
une fondation
bravo l'anc et ben voilà mesdames
messieurs c'était tout le monde à moi ce
que je veux dire avant de finir c'est
qu'il ya un mec qui m'énerve vraiment
mais vraiment grave
c'est mon fils gaston qui a deux ans et
demi parce qu'il est en train de me
piquer ma femme voilà c'est dit gaston
la mère passe trop de temps avec toi je
suis très jaloux ici avec lui et si avec
lui bon voilà donc c'était tout le monde
en parle rendez-vous dans quinze jours
merci laurent ruquier mais aussi
laetitia casta heureux de vous avoir
connu merci patricia gaillou merci andré
bercoff et merci à tous les gens à
catherine barma et serge khalfon à tous
les gens qui ont travaillé sur
l'émission merci beaucoup à dans quinze
jours cha
[Musique]